All right, lady, you know that Lee was just shooting his movie in Oklahoma City. And the movie gave him a place to stay because he was there for months. Right. But for two of those weeks, me and the kids came out to join him and the place he was staying in that the movie provided. It was just too small to your whole family. We're a whole family. He went on Airbnb, got us the most beautiful, spacious place to stay. With the nicest host. Well you know if you're planning a trip or you're working
好的，女士，你知道李刚在俄克拉荷马城拍摄他的电影。因为他在那里待了几个月，电影公司为他提供了住处。没错。但在那几周里，我和孩子们去和他团聚，电影公司提供的住处对我们全家来说太小了。我们是一大家子人。他上了Airbnb，为我们找了一个最漂亮、宽敞的住处。房东也特别好。嗯，你知道如果你正在计划旅行或者在某地工作，想住Airbnb，我觉得你们一定要看看他们的“房客最爱”，因为那是Airbnb上最受欢迎的房源。哦！我们住的就是“房客最爱”！我们住过“房客最爱”！你吓到我了！抱歉，这是真的！你太激动了！我是很激动。嗯，是的，我的意思是，你住的是别人住过的房子，而且你知道它评价很好。听着，我们是Airbnb的忠实粉丝，原因有很多。
somewhere and you want to stay at an Airbnb, I think you guys got to check out their guest favorite because those are the most loved homes on Airbnb. Oh! We were a guest favorite! We were in a guest favorite! You scared me! So sorry, it's true! You're so excited! I was. Well, yeah, I mean, you're actually getting a home other people have stayed in, and you know it's been well reviewed. Well, listen, we are huge fans of Airbnb for so many reasons.
所以，为了你的下一次冒险，考虑一下Airbnb吧。有了Fizz忠诚度计划，你只需拥有一个移动套餐就能获得奖励。你知道，就是发短信之类的。如果你的移动套餐没有提供额外流量和现金抵扣等奖励，那你用的就不是Fizz。今天就切换吧。适用相关条款。详情请见fizz.ca。欢迎来到德怀特演讲的第二杯。
So for your next adventure, consider Airbnb. With the Fizz loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. Welcome to your second drink of Dwight's speech.
这一集播出后，我们收到了大量的粉丝来信。是的，确实。内容都是关于我们在节目中跑题聊到的《指环王》。没错，可能说错了一些东西。大家对此有反应。确实有。我想你说的是，
We had a fan mail flurry after this episode aired. Yep, we did. And it was all about our off topic banter that we had about Lord of the Rings. Yep, might have said something wrong. People reacted to it. They did. And I guess you said,
莫多（Modor）？嗯。而不是魔多（Mordor）。听起来像我。是的。好吧，这让大家抓狂了。是的，确实。
Modor? Mm-hmm. Instead of Mordor. Sounds like me. Yep. Okay. Well, it drove people crazy. Yep, it did.. Sounds like me. Yeah. Okay. Well, it drove people crazy. Yeah, it did.
我没注意到。好吧。尼基·S写信说，你们关于《指环王》的讨论太搞笑了。萨马诺沃说，天哪，整个《指环王》的解析让我笑得要死。名字读错让我尴尬得起鸡皮疙瘩。我很抱歉。但这确实让我笑得很开心。是的。盖伊·S写信说，安吉拉，这让《指环王》的死忠粉快疯了。
I didn't notice. Well. Nikki S wrote in to say, your Lord of the Rings discussion was hilarious. And Samanovo said, oh God, the whole breakdown of Lord of the Rings cracked me the hell up. The butchering of the names made me cringe. I'm sorry. But it also made me laugh so much. Yeah. Guy S wrote in and said, Angela, it was driving this Lord of the Rings nerd crazy.
对此贝基回复说，哦，太痛苦了。我很抱歉，盖伊。我很抱歉，贝基。我很抱歉，每一位《指环王》的粉丝。有时候我说话会漏掉一个字母。这很正常。好吧，安吉，显然我也让大家抓狂了，因为我读不出索伦（Swarson）的名字。哦，你现在又来了。你又来了。索伦（Sauron）。好吧。
To which Becky replied, oh, so painful. I'm sorry, Guy. I'm sorry, Becky. I'm sorry, every Lord of the Rings fan. Sometimes I like leave out a letter in things. It happens. Well, Ange, apparently I also drove people nuts because of my inability to pronounce Swarson. Oh, now you're doing it again. You're doing it again. Sauron. Okay.
Iamtarth说那是全大写的索伦（Sauron）。奥黛丽写信解释说魔多是一个国家。那是一个充满纯粹邪恶和毁灭的国家，到处都是怪物、熔岩和邪恶。有很多熔岩。熔岩？有很多熔岩。好吧。我想那也是黑暗魔君索伦的领地。没错。
Iamtarth said that it is Sauron in all caps. And Audrey wrote in to explain that Mordor is a country. It is a country of pure evil and destruction, full of monsters, lava and evil. Lots of lava. Lava? Lots of lava. Okay. And I guess it is also the land of the Dark Lord of Sauron. That's right.
好吧。所以在你们重听这一集，听到我们再次糟蹋所有这些名字和地点之前，我们只是想让你们知道，我们听到了你们的声音。我们非常抱歉。是的。我们提前道歉。另外，伙计们，前阵子，Cartooner Radio的人制作了我们一些播客的动画片段。他们做了这一集，关于《指环王》的对话。那些家伙太有才了。所以如果你错过了那些片段，可以在我们Instagram个人资料的链接中找到。但是珍娜，在我们离开《指环王》的话题之前，我还有一封信。
Okay. So before you re-listen to this episode and hear us butcher all of these names and places again, we just wanted to let you know that we hurt you. We are so sorry. Yes. We apologize in advance. Also, you guys, a while back, the folks over at Cartooner Radio, they did animated clips of some of our podcasts. They did this one, the Lord of the Rings conversation. Those guys are so talented. So if you missed those clips, you can find them at the link in our bio on Instagram. But Jenna, before we leave the Lord of the Rings conversation, I do have one more letter.
塔姆拉写信说，珍娜，我真的觉得你会喜欢《指环王》。电影是基于一个任务，把戒指送到一个地方，就像电影《1917》一样，但主角是霍比特人。它们太棒了。塔姆拉，我喜欢你知道我喜欢有任务的电影。我真的非常喜欢。在我们解析《边缘》（The Edge）时，萨姆说《指环王》和《边缘》很像。
Tamra wrote in to say, Jenna, I really think you would like the Lord of the Rings. The movies are based on a task, getting the ring to a place just like the movie 1917, but with hobbits. They are amazing. Tamara, I love that you know that I love a movie with a task. I really, really do. And during our breakdown of The Edge, Sam said that Lord of the Rings was similar to The Edge.
所以我非常感兴趣。好吧。我可能会看这部。哦，所以我非常感兴趣。好吧。我可能会看这部。哦，我会很高兴的。我觉得这也会是一部很好的家庭电影之夜电影。我说得对吗？是的。全家一起看？
So I am very intrigued. Okay. I might watch this one. Oh, so I am very intrigued. Okay. I might watch this one. Oh, I would be so happy. I feel like this would be a good family movie night movie too. Am I right? Yeah. For the whole family?
是的。好吧。是的。好吧。兽人很吓人。它们比《哈利·波特》里的东西更吓人吗？它们比《哈利·波特》里那种阴森的东西更吓人吗？你的孩子多大了？
Yes. Okay. Yes. All right. The orcs are scary. Are they scarier than something in Harry Potter? Are they scarier than the thing in Harry Potter that is like spooky? How old are your kids?
10岁和13岁。那完全没问题。没关系吗？是的。好吧。兽人吓到我了。确实。但我也不喜欢僵尸，我也不喜欢恐怖电影。
10 and 13. It's perfectly fine. It's okay? Yeah. Okay. The orcs scare me. They do. But I also don't like zombies and I don't like scary movies.
这是《指环王》里让我觉得非常恐怖的部分。好吧。只是兽人预警，萨姆。兽人预警。这是一个很好的兽人预警，是的。我太想和你们俩一起看《指环王》了。好吧，继续。我们在这一集中讨论的另一个大话题是帕姆的婚礼颜色是薰衣草色。
It's the one part of Lord of the Rings that's very scary to me. Okay. Just orc warning, Sam. Orc warning. This is a good orc warning, yes. I need a Lord of the Rings we watched to happen with you both so badly. Well, moving on. Another big discussion we had in this episode was about Pam's wedding color being lavender.
是的。我想我说过，我要去看看她的婚礼照片，确认一下她的伴娘是否穿了薰衣草色。但是女士。什么？玛丽·B写信说，什么婚礼照片？罗伊和帕姆没有婚礼照片，因为他们没结婚。当然没有。好吧，我们这一集也收到了一些粉丝非常好的发现。
Yeah. And I guess I said something about, I'm gonna go check her wedding photos and confirm that her bridesmaids wore lavender. But lady. What? Mary B. wrote in to say, what wedding photos? Roy and Pam didn't have wedding photos since they didn't get married. There are none, of course. Well we also had some really good fan catches from this episode.
At 42 Wallaby Way写道，我注意到当吉姆转动地球仪随机决定去哪里度假时，他的手指落在了非洲的某个地方。但在最后，当帕姆问他要去哪里时，他说，澳大利亚。嗯。那是一个很好的发现。凯莉·M写信说，在8分06秒，你可以看到会议室窗户里吊杆麦克风操作员的倒影。被抓包了。亚伦·T写道，你们谈到了20分25秒时人群中的巫师，但19分42秒时的外星人呢？我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。是的，安吉拉。我也看到了那个评论。他们甚至寄来了一张照片。在19分42秒确实有一个完整的外星人。好吧，就是这样，各位。这就是你们的德怀特演讲的第二杯。
At 42 Wallaby Way wrote in and said, I noticed that when Jim spins the globe to decide randomly where he'll go on his vacation, his finger lands somewhere in Africa. But at the end, when Pam asks where he's going, he says, Australia. Mm-hmm. That was a good catch. Callie M. wrote in to say, at eight minutes and six seconds, you can see the reflection of the boom guy in the conference room window. Busted. And Aaron T. wrote in and said, you talked about the wizard in the crowd at 20 minutes
现在是我们的解析环节。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，
and 25 seconds, but what about the alien at 19 minutes and 42 seconds? We got a lot of mail about that. Yes, Angela. I saw that comment too. They even sent in a photo. There is a full alien at 19 minutes and 42 seconds. Well, there you go, everybody. That is your second drink of Dwight's speech.
并讲述只有两个身临其境的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。早上好，《办公室》女士。我看到你在做什么了。你看到了我在做什么。你对这一集稍微致敬了一下，这一集是……德怀特演讲，第二季第17集，由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，由……执导。
And now here's our breakdown. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office
开拍！查尔斯·麦克道格尔！哇，我的嗓子已经喊哑了。现在开车的人肯定在想，你喊哑的可不止嗓子。我知道。才说了三句话。谢谢，你喊“早上好，《办公室》女士”的时候我正在开车。好吧，我会收敛一点。
and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Good morning, Office ladies. I see what you're doing there. You see what I'm doing. You're tipping your hat a little to this episode, which is... Dwight's Speech Season 2, Episode 17, written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by...
看，我要认真了，我现在要用NPR（美国国家公共电台）的语调了。哦。NPR语调。我要做总结了，但我会说得很温柔。像这样？是的。NPR语调？是的。
Action! Charles McDougall! Wow, I've blown up my voice already. Someone driving right now is like, that's not the only thing you blew out. I know. Three sentences in. Thanks, I was driving when you were like, good morning, Office Ladies. All right, I'll tone it down.
嗨，欢迎来到《办公室》女士。我是安吉拉·金赛。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我们是最好的朋友，我们正在解析《办公室》里德怀特演讲的那一集。这是总结。好吧，我现在停下来。德怀特被评为年度最佳销售员。
Look, I'll get real, I'm going to NPR it now. Oh. NPR voice. I'm going to do my summary, but I'm going to do it real gentle. Like that? Yeah. NPR voice? Yeah.
这是一个巨大的荣誉。这是一个巨大的荣誉。是的，结果他必须在1000人面前发表演讲，他非常紧张。所以他去找迈克尔寻求建议。然后他去找吉姆寻求建议。最后他去了会议现场。
Hi, welcome to Office Ladies. I'm Angela Kinsey. I'm Jenna Fisher. We're best friends, and we're breaking down an episode of Dwight's speech from the office. Here's a summary. All right, I'll stop it now. Dwight is named salesperson of the year.
但与此同时，帕姆在办公室里当着吉姆的面做婚礼准备。所以他决定是时候去度假了。去度假。还有一场恒温器战争正在进行。是的。是的。恒温器战争。我曾告诉我们的一些编剧关于我们经历过的恒温器战争。
It's a big honor. It's a huge honor. Yeah, and as a result, he has to give a speech in front of a thousand people and he's really nervous. So he goes to Michael for advice. Then he goes to Jim for advice. Eventually he goes to the conference.
因为你们经历过。我们在1-800-Dennis经历过一场，结果是在恒温器上加了一个锁箱。哦，天哪。带钥匙的。事情变得严重了。事情变得严重了。所以我不知道。你是哪一派？你是怕冷还是怕热？带钥匙的。事情变得严重了。事情变得严重了。所以我……你呢？
But meanwhile, Pam is doing wedding prep at work in front of Jim. So he decides it's time for a vacation. A vacay. Also there is a thermostat war going on. Yes. Yes. Thermostat war. Now I had told some of our writers about the thermostat war that we had.
你是怕冷还是怕热？我是珍娜。我的意思是，对于那些可能不知道我们在录制这个播客时你穿着羽绒服的听众来说。现在，我有一件T恤——伙计们，说真的，她穿着一件羽绒服。这不是开玩笑。我穿了一件T恤，一件带帽衫的运动衫，
Because you had one. We had one at 1-800-Dennis that resulted in a lock box over the thermostat. Oh dear. With a key. It got serious. It got serious. So I have no idea. What were you? Were you a colder or a hotter? I with a key. It got serious. It got serious. So I have- What about you?
然后外面套了一件巨大的羽绒服。我还拥有一件写着“总是很冷”的运动衫。那是别人送给我的礼物。我甚至不是自己买的。人们了解你。人们了解我。不，我总是很冷。不管什么原因，我坐着打电话的地方
Were you a colder or a hotter? I was a Jenna. I mean, for our listeners who might not know that you're wearing a puffy coat as we record this podcast. Right now, I have a t- Guys, literally, she's wearing a puffy coat. That's not a joke. I have a t-shirt on, a sweatshirt with a hoodie,
是所有冷气吹到的地方，就像我们的侧翼，而IT部门的那些人，一点冷气都没有。所以他们是最容易出汗的。他们总是很烦躁。他们会满头大汗地走过来，把恒温器调低。然后他们就走开了。我们冷了，又会把它调回去。哇。
and then I have an enormous puffer over that. I also own a sweatshirt that says always cold. It was a gift to me. I didn't even buy it for myself. People know you. People know me. No, I was always cold. And for whatever reason, where I sat on the phones
他们讨厌我们的角落。IT部门的人讨厌我们的角落。第一个速记事实。我们收到了很多关于会议中心，关于会议本身的问题。有很多好奇心。例如，来自玛丽·安·洛登斯、格蕾丝·D和梅尔·阿萨科的粉丝提问，演讲是在哪里拍摄的？然后苏·波茨问，我们是雇了一堆临时演员，还是只用了酒店现有的工作人员？好吧，我联系了我们的制片主任，肯特·兹博纳克。
is where all the air went, like our wing, and the guys in the IT department, no air went to them. So they were like the sweatiest. They were always annoyed. They would come over really sweaty and like shove the thermostat down. And then they'd walk away. We'd get cold and we'd crank it back up. Wow.
所以制片主任是拿到剧本并弄清楚你需要做的所有实际工作来完成一集拍摄的人。所以格雷格·丹尼尔斯负责一集的所有创意方面，而肯特·兹博纳克负责实际操作。以及后勤。我怎么把人弄到那里？
They hated our corner. The IT guys hated our corner. Fast fact number one. We had a lot of questions about the convention center, the convention itself. A lot of curiosity. For example, fan question from Mary Ann Lodens and Grace D and Mel Ahsako, where was the speech filmed? And then Sue Potts asked, did we hire a bunch of extras or did we just use existing hotel people? Well, I reached out to our line producer, Kent Zbornak.
我们在哪里拍摄？成本是多少？是的。我们如何利用预算来完成这项工作？所有这些事情。是的。例如，他会是给菲尔·谢提供13个健身球预算的人。他会说，这是你的健身球预算。
So a line producer is the person who gets the script and figures out all of the practical stuff that you need to do to make an episode happen. So whereas Greg Daniels is in charge of all the creative aspects of an episode, Kent Zbornak would be in charge of the practicals. And the logistics. How do I get people there?
所以他负责所有这些数字和事情。他说我们只在环球影城喜来登酒店拍摄了一天。我在很久以前的博客里写过我们有500名临时演员，但肯特说我们没有500名临时演员。我们有400名临时演员。是的。还有100个假人。尸体？是的。假尸体。没有胳膊和腿的躯干，穿着西装。是的。
Where are we filming? What does it cost? Yes. How do we make this work with our budget? All that kind of stuff. Yes. For example, he would be a person who would give Phil Shea a budget for 13 fitness orbs. He'd be like, here's your fitness orb budget.
还有五个假人管理员，负责把它们搬到房间里，根据拍摄需要放在不同的地方。我的意思是，那简直是疯了。那简直是疯了。我的笔记里确实写着我们大约有400名临时演员，这是我们有史以来最多的临时演员。是的，这是真的。
So he's in charge of all those numbers and things. He said that we filmed for only one day at the Universal Studios Sheridan Hotel. Now I had written in my blog a while ago that we had 500 extras, but Kent said we did not have 500 extras. We had 400 extras. Yes. And 100 dummies. Bodies? Yes. Fake bodies. Torsoes with no arms and legs, dressed up in suits. Yeah.
所以肯特说假人大多在后面和两侧。是的。他说，如果你暂停仔细看，你能找到它们，但我逐帧看了，我一个都没找到。我的意思是，我真的找了。所以只有三名演员去了会议现场，你知道，雷恩，显然，德怀特演讲，然后是迈克尔和我自己。
And five dummy wranglers, people who carried them around the room and put them in different places, depending on the shots. I mean, that is crazy town. That is crazy town. I did have in my notes that we had about 400 extras and it's the most extras we had ever had. Yes, this is true.
房间其实很大。如果我的记忆没错，他们把假人放在了靠后的位置。所以看起来房间一直填满到后面。我不认为你能发现。我觉得那会很难。他提到查尔斯·麦克道格尔非常担心你会看到这些假人。所以管理员们确实经常移动它们。假人管理员。假人管理员。
So Kent said that the dummies were mostly in the back and on the sides. Yes. He said, if you pause and look, you can find them, but I went frame by frame and I could not find any. I mean, I really looked. So there were only three cast members that went to the convention and it was, you know, Rain, obviously, Dwight Speech, and then Michael and myself.
对我来说有趣的是——那是我们的书，假人管理员？不，那是肯特·兹博纳克的关于如何对付我们的书。是的。有很多临时演员。这是我见过的最多的一次。我们从来没有真正需要为那么多人提供午餐。
The room was actually really big. And if my memory serves, they had the dummies sort of way towards the back. So it just looked like the room was filled all the way to the back. I wouldn't think that you could catch it. I think that'd be pretty hard. He mentioned that Charles McDougall was really worried that you were going to see these dummies. And so the Wranglers really moved them around a lot. The dummy Wranglers. The dummy Wranglers.
我记得午餐时间到了，餐饮服务，那是塞尔吉奥，加上所有其他额外的人，那是我们的餐饮公司。所以看到我们如何管理那么多人是很有趣的。我很高兴我们只需要做一天。他说我们在12小时的拍摄日里完成了47个摄像机位设置。现在，让我为你们解析一下。当你拍摄场景时，你可能会拍像接待处那样的场景，
What's interesting to me- Is that our book, the dummy Wranglers? No, that's Kent Subornat's book about dealing with us. Yeah. There were a lot of extras. It was the most I'd ever seen. We had never really had to provide lunch for that many people.
但那是三到四个不同的摄像机位设置。所以你通常会为每个机位设置拍四到七次，因为，你知道，然后你移动摄像机再拍一次，但这让我大吃一惊。他说我们早上7点开始，7点半左右收工，设法拍摄了七又八分之四页，
I remember when it came time for lunch, the catering was way, it was like Sergio, plus all these other extra guys, that was our catering company. So it was kind of interesting to see how we managed that many people. And I was glad we only had to do it for one day. He said that we did 47 camera setups in a 12-hour shoot day. Now, let me break that down for you guys. When you do scenes, you might do like one scene at reception,
我想这是一种说七页半的华丽方式。第二个速记事实，雷恩·威尔逊在这一集拍摄时病得很重。非常，非常重。所以我们刚刚向你们解释了雷恩·威尔逊在这一集拍摄时病得很重。非常，非常重。所以我们刚刚向你们解释了所有关于计划这个工作日的事情。我们不得不——猜猜发生了什么？是的。
but it's three or four different camera setups. So you'll do what usually like four to seven takes per camera setup, because, you know, and then you move the cameras and you do it again, but that blew my mind. He said that we started at 7 a.m., wrapped around 7.30, and managed to shoot seven and four eighths pages,
哦，是的。说吧。我们不得不，他们都安排好了，然后他们不得不取消并重新安排到一周后的另一天。不仅仅是提前几天取消。基本上，雷恩在这一集开始时就病了，然后这一天安排好了，如果我没记错的话，是在周三或周四，我们已经在办公区拍了一些办公室场景，我们还要继续。我想是周三。是的。我也就此联系了肯特。他说他总是喜欢把这些外景拍摄
which I guess is a fancy way to say seven and a half. Fast fact number two, Rainn Wilson was very sick for this episode. Very, very sick. So we just explained to you everything Rainn Wilson was very sick for this episode. Very, very sick. So we just explained to you everything that went into planning this workday. We had to- Guess what happened? Yeah.
安排在周二或周三。是的。继续。这也是我记得的。就像周三，但我们已经在周一、周二在办公区拍摄了，就像主办公大楼。我记得我们只有一天的酒店使用权。
Oh, yeah. Go. We had to, they had it all scheduled and then they had to cancel it and reschedule it for a different day by a week. Not just cancel it like a few days ahead. Basically, Rain was sick the beginning of the episode and then the day this was scheduled, if I remember it was sort of like on a Wednesday or Thursday, we'd already done some office scenes in the bullpen and we were going later. I think it was a Wednesday. Yeah. I reached out to Kent about this as well. And he said he always liked to put these location shoots
这是一件大事，因为他们必须预订这个房间等等。是的。然后我们雇了所有的临时演员等等。我周三早上醒来，接到了我们第二助理导演的电话，他们说，安吉拉，酒店拍摄取消了。雷恩病得太重了。他病得太重了。他的医生说，你不能去。我当时想，天哪。所以他们现在有点手忙脚乱，想弄清楚周三会是什么样子。好吧，我在家里接到了电话，珍娜，酒店拍摄取消了。你需要来上班。我们现在要回到
on a Tuesday or a Wednesday. Yes. And go ahead. That's what I remember too. It was like a Wednesday, but we'd already been filming in the bullpen Monday, Tuesday, like the main office building. And I remember we only had the hotel for one day.
办公室拍摄了。所以我那天休息，突然又得去工作了。是的。好吧，我确实给雷恩打了电话。他说这是他在《办公室》工作10年来唯一一次因为生病而无法去上班。但他发烧超过102度。他说医生来了，说你不能去上班。雷恩有极好的职业道德。我不怀疑他缺席的原因。他病得很重。好吧，我们有一个来自克里斯·博德纳的粉丝提问，他有点注意到了。他说雷恩·威尔逊在这一集里生病了吗？因为他的声音听起来像感冒了，雷恩说其实声音的问题是因为他在演讲时尖叫，他有点喊哑了嗓子。但你其实可以在会议
It was a big deal because they had to reserve this room and everything. Yes. And then we had all the extras hired and everything. I woke up Wednesday morning and I got a call from our second AD and they said, Angela, the hotel's been canceled. Rain is too sick. He's too sick. Like his doctor said, you cannot go. And I was like, oh my gosh. And so they were sort of scrambling now to figure out what Wednesday was going to look like. Well, I got a call at home, Jenna, the hotel has been canceled. You need to come into work. We're going to be shooting back
室里听到，在我们搬到酒店之前。你可以看出他快要病倒了。我真的能看出来。我在会议室里听到了他的声音。那是在我们去酒店之前，他听起来确实病了。所以我同意你的看法，克里斯。我不知道他是否接到了格雷格·丹尼尔斯的电话，告诉他
in the office now. So I got the day off and I was suddenly had to work. Yes. Well, I actually called rain about it. And he said that it is the only time in 10 years of working on the office that he was not able to come to work for a day. But he had a fever over 102. He said a doctor came and said, you cannot go to work. Rain has a fantastic work ethic. And I don't doubt that for him to miss. He was very ill. Well, we had a fan question from Chris Bodnar who kind of clocked it. He said was Rainn Wilson sick during this episode because his voice sounds like he might have a cold and rainn said actually that the voice thing is because he was screaming during the speech and he kind of blew out his voice. But you can actually hear in the conference
这是他最精彩的表演，因为他在这一集里真的很好。他在这一集里真的，真的很好。但是的，我的意思是，另一件事你也应该知道，雷恩真的不想错过工作，因为他知道那一天投入了多少，临时演员，酒店，外景拍摄。所以我认为他——假人管理员。
room before we ever moved to the hotel. You can tell he's coming down with it. I could really tell. I heard his voice in the conference room. That's before we went to the hotel, and he sounded legit sick. So I agree with you, Chris. I wonder if he got a phone call from Greg Daniels telling him
假人管理员。我想他真的在努力坚持，然后他的身体实在撑不住了。是的。好吧。第三个速记事实。这是我在Dunderpedia上发现的一点琐事。Dunderpedia，伙计们，是《办公室》的维基百科。太棒了。
it was his finest performance, because he's really good in this episode. He's really, really good in this episode. But yeah, I mean, the other thing too, you should know is that Rain really didn't want to miss work because he knew how much went into that day, the extras, the hotel, the location shoot. So I think he was- The dummy wranglers.
全是《办公室》的事实。太棒了。我觉得这很迷人。所以这一集于2006年3月2日在美利坚合众国播出。然而，在加拿大，它提前一天播出了。哦。它提前一天播出，这是由于与《与名人滑冰》季终集的档期冲突。
The dummy wranglers. I think he was really trying to power it out and then his body just couldn't. Yeah. All right. Fast fact number three. This was a little bit of trivia that I found on Dunderpedia. Dunderpedia guys is the Wikipedia of the office. It's great.
所以在美利坚合众国，我们在NBC播出，《与名人滑冰》在福克斯播出，但在加拿大，它们都在同一个电视网播出，这个全球电视网，而《与名人滑冰》的结局和这一集在同一时间，所以他们不得不让我们提前一天播出。所以加拿大的每个人都提前一天看到了这一集。好吧，那怎么样？是的。谁参加了《与名人滑冰》？它只播了一季。有人受伤吗？我不记得有很多伤病，但我奇怪地记得这个节目。我不记得。它只播了一季。所以它不是热门。我想它很好。我有点像它没有火起来。好吧，
It's just all office facts. It's great. And I found this charming. So this episode aired in the United States on March 2nd in 2006. However, in Canada, it aired the day before. Oh. It aired a day early, and this was due to a scheduling conflict with the season finale of Skating with Celebrities.
所以这里我给你《与名人滑冰》的演员阵容。我真的很好奇。他们把一个名人与一个职业滑冰搭档配对。所以克里斯蒂·斯旺森、吉莉安·巴伯里、布鲁斯·詹纳、戴夫·库利尔、黛比·吉布森和托德·布里奇斯。克里斯蒂·斯旺森赢了。嘿。她击败了吉莉安·巴伯里和她的搭档，赢得了该节目第一季也是唯一一季的冠军。哇。是的。
So in the United States, we aired on NBC and Skating with Celebrities aired on Fox, but in Canada, they both aired on the same network, this global television network, and the finale of Skating with Celebrities was at the same time as this episode, so they had to air us one day early. So everyone in Canada got to see this one day early. Well, how about that? Yeah. Who was on Skating with Celebrities? It only ran for one season. Did people get injured? I don't remember a bunch of injuries, but I weirdly remember the show. I don't. It only went for one season. So it wasn't a hit. I guess it's way good. I'm kind of like it wasn't it didn't take off. Okay,
哦，这里有个有趣的事。就在第二天，宣布它被取消了。哦，不。所以就像，我赢了。取消。取消。我想要保龄球与名人。我会参加的。
so here I'll give you the cast of skating with celebrities. I'm really curious. They matched a celebrity with a pro skating partner. So Kristy Swanson, Gillian Barbary, Bruce Jenner, Dave Coulier, Debbie Gibson, and Todd Bridges. Kristy Swanson won. Hey. She defeated Gillian Barbary and her partner to win the show's first and only championship. Wow. Yeah.
我会参加的。你知道，前几天我连续打了四个全中，安吉拉。我得到了，那是什么？那比火鸡（连续三次全中）还多。你知道，前几天我连续打了四个全中，安吉拉。我得到了，那是什么？那比火鸡还多。我只是喜欢那种现实冠军赛的想法，在那里我可以喝啤酒，吃一片披萨，同时进行我的活动。
Oh, here's something interesting. The very next day, it was announced that it was canceled. Oh, no. So it's like, I won. Canceled. Canceled. I want bowling with celebrities. I'd do it.
保龄球与名人。保龄球与名人。那个把豆袋扔进后院洞里的游戏叫什么？玉米洞（Cornhole）。我喜欢玉米洞。玉米洞与名人。玉米洞与名人。
I would do it. You know, I got four strikes in a row the other day, Angela. I got like, what is that? That's more than a turkey. You know, I got four strikes in a row the other day, Angela. I got like, what is that? That's more than a turkey. I just like the idea of like some kind of reality championship where I can have beer and like a slice of pizza while doing my activity.
我一直都在做那个。我的意思是，我不是，我有点，你知道，不是大名人，但是。玉米洞也是某种肮脏短语的代名词吗？可能，它可能和你的屁股有关，萨姆？《瘪四与大头蛋》，他们没说过吗？你不需要每件事都看着我。那是你屁股眼的代称吗？
Bowling with celebrities. Bowling with celebrities. What's that thing where you throw bean bags into a hole in your backyard? Cornhole. I love cornhole. Cornhole with celebrities. Cornhole with celebrities.
是的，确实是。所以也许不要和名人玩玉米洞。它仍然非常有趣。我的意思是，事情是这样的。这是我的保龄球策略。我迫不及待想听听。别剪掉这个。每次我走过去，我只是试着对准那个小中心三角形。
I already do that all the time. I mean, I'm not, I'm sort of, you know, not major celebrity, but. Is cornhole also a phrase for something dirty? Probably, it has to do with your butt, maybe, Sam? Beavis and butt head, didn't they say? You don't have to look to me for every. Is that a reference for your butt hole?
箭头？嗯。是的。然后我试着看着那个，然后我把它滚下去。球走得超级慢。好吧。因为我通常用10磅重的球打保龄球。我就像在和孩子们抢他们的球。这太迷人了。
Yes, it is. So maybe no cornhole with celebrities. It's still really fun. I mean, here's the thing. Here's my bowling strategy. I can't wait to hear it. Don't cut this. Every time I walk up and I just try to line up with that little center triangle.
球走得超级慢，超级慢。然后我得到了一个全中，但就像，它花了大约五分钟。就像咚、咚、咚、咚。然后我想因为球走得太慢了，我通常会剩下一两个。我非常接近得到一个全中。这就是我打保龄球的方式。
The arrow? Uh-huh. Yeah. And then I try to look at that and then I roll it down. The ball goes super slow. Okay. Cause I usually bowl with like a 10 pound ball. I'm like going fighting the kids for their balls. It's fascinating.
别停止谈论它，安吉拉。继续告诉我更多细节。我要么那样做，要么就打出沟球。我本来会猜的。所以这对我来说很有趣。我会说现在我非常像你。所以这对我来说很有趣。我会说现在，我非常感兴趣。你花时间对准它，你做那个动作，这对我来说非常有趣。你知道，你瞄准箭头，因为我可能把你归类为那种人。
And the ball goes super slow, super slow. And then I get like a strike, but it's like, it takes like five minutes. It's like dunk, dunk, dunk, dunk. And then I think cause the ball's going so slow, I usually there's like one or two left. I come really close to getting a strike. So that's how I bowl.
随心所欲。不是随心所欲，而是那种你会说，我要把它扔出去。我要用力扔出去。我为你做了那个动作，这样你就明白我的意思了。哦，闭嘴。你闭嘴。是时候休息一下了。哦，如果还有人想听，我们要进入这一集了。有一些非常好的东西。我有很多有趣的事情要说。我也是。而且甚至不会是关于保龄球的。可能是。可能是。好吧，休息后见。因为治疗应该让人感觉触手可及。通过在线治疗，你可以以合理的价格获得高质量的护理。拥有超过30,000名治疗师，BetterHelp是世界上最大的在线治疗平台
Don't stop talking about it, Angela. Keep telling me more details. I either do that or I just get a gutter ball. I would have pegged. So it's interesting to me. I will say now I'm very you. So it's interesting to me. I will say now, I'm very interested. It's very interesting to me that you take the time to line it up and you do the thing. You know, you go for the arrow because I might have pegged you as a person.
并已在全球为超过500万人提供服务。而且很方便。你可以点击按钮加入会议，它能帮助你将治疗融入忙碌的生活中。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并可随时免费更换治疗师。你的幸福是值得的。
Willy nilly. Not Willy nilly, but where you're like, I'm going to just chunk it. I'm going to chunk it real hard. I did it for you so you'd understand what I meant. Oh, shut up. You shut up. It's time for a break. Oh, if anyone is still wanting to listen, we're going to get into the episode. There's some really good stuff. I have a lot of fun things to say. I do too. And it's not even going to be about bowling. Might be. Might be. All right, we'll see you after the break. because therapy should feel accessible. And with online therapy, you get quality care at a price that makes sense. And with over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform
如果你正在考虑开始治疗，你可以试试BetterHelp。今天就访问betterhelp.com/office ladies，首次月费可享10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp，H-E-L-P点com斜杠office ladies。这是一个里斯花生酱杯的声音实验。我们正在寻找听到里斯的最佳方式，这样你就会买更多。我们开始吧。里斯。里斯。里斯。里斯。里斯。里斯。
and has served over 5 million people globally. And it's convenient. You can join a session with a click of the button and it helps you to fit therapy into your busy life. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Your wellbeing is worth it.
里斯。嘿，走开，你这个小捣蛋鬼。里斯。里斯。里斯。花生酱杯。那个呼吸声听起来很诡异，我说得对吗？让我们开始这一集吧。
And if you are thinking of starting therapy, you can give BetterHelp a try. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp, H-E- e l p dot com slash office ladies. This is a Reese's peanut butter cup sound experiment. We're looking to find the perfect way to hear Reese's so you'll buy more of them. Here we go. Reese's. Reese's. Reese's. Reese's. Reeses. Reeses.
开始吧。我们有一个冷开场。迈克尔和德怀特在扔橄榄球，同时讨论公司的一些困境。这不重要。我不认为这甚至意味着什么。我永远不会忘记。好吧。这个冷开场。
Reeses. Hey, get out of here, you little stinker. Reeses. Reeses. Reeses. Peanut butter cups. That breathy one sounded very creepy, am I right? Let's get started with this episode.
哦，天哪。你想知道为什么吗？说吧。好吧。所以吉姆抢走了球。他把它扔给菲利斯。是的。菲利斯把它扔给克里德，德怀特跑过去，
Let's do it. We have a cold open. Michael and Dwight are throwing a football while they discuss some dilemma at corporate. It's not important. I don't think it doesn't even mean anything. I will never forget. Okay. This cold open.
只有雷恩·威尔逊会做的那样，雷恩是，他全力以赴，伙计们。如果剧本说擒抱、推搡，你就会飞出去。因为雷恩饰演的德怀特是全情投入的。所以他把瑞安扑倒在地，他狠狠地推了克里德。然后他跑向站在会计部旁边的莱斯利·大卫·贝克。你看不见的是他身后站着一个娇小的金发人。哦。嗯。雷恩冲向莱斯利，基本上对他用了海斯曼擒抱。是的。真的给了他一个僵硬的手臂推搡。莱斯利没预料到。
Oh boy. Do you want to know why? Tell. Okay. So Jim steals the ball. He tosses it to Phyllis. Yep. Phyllis tosses it to Creed, Dwight runs over,
哦，天哪。剧本里并没有说他要推莱斯利。那天我们有一位特技协调员。我们计划得非常周密。让我告诉你一件事。莱斯利没准备好迎接那次推搡。好吧。我们计划得非常周密。让我告诉你一件事。莱斯利没准备好迎接那次推搡。好吧。我想也许，也许和特技演员一起，他得到了一个轻微的拍打之类的。
and only the way that Rainn Wilson would do, Rainn is, he goes full out guys. If the script says tackle, shove, you're going to go flying. Because Rainn as Dwight is like all in. So like he tackles Ryan to the ground, He shoves the heck out of Creed. And then he runs towards Leslie David Baker, who is standing by accounting. What you cannot see is there is a petite blonde person standing behind him. Oh. Mm-hmm. Rain runs at Leslie and like heismans him basically. Yeah. Really gives him the stiff arm shove. Leslie was not expecting it.
但雷恩全速冲向他，推了他。莱斯利飞了出去。他失去了——你可以在这一集里看到。他完全失去了平衡。他几乎屁股朝上。好吧，是的。但有人直接在他身后。娇小的金发人。
Oh dear. It wasn't really in the script that he was going to shove Leslie. We had a stunt coordinator that day. We planned this out like super duper. Let me tell you something. Leslie was not ready for that shove. Okay. We planned this out like super duper. Let me tell you something. Leslie was not ready for that show. Okay. I think maybe, maybe with the stunt guy, he got a brisk little like tap or something.
一个娇小的金发人。所以当莱斯利失去平衡时，他开始向后翻滚，我就在下面。哇。嗯。我就在下面。好吧，这很疯狂，因为我记得我们练习了很久。我记得它是因为我所做的就是坐在接待台前，我曾想
But rain came at him full throttle and like shoved him. Leslie went flying. He lost his- You can see it in the episode. He lost his balance completely. He went almost butt overhead. Okay, yeah. But there was someone directly behind him. Tiny blonde.
对自己说，我需要在这里待两个小时吗？这就是我想的。这就是我想的。这就是我想的。他们说，你知道，他们绝对不想让我坐在办公桌前。他们想让我走到会计部的边缘。有时他们会让我们这样做。如果主办公室办公区有一个场景，他们想得到每个人的反应镜头，他们会有点让凯文和我的角色出来。
A tiny blonde person. So when Leslie lost his balance, he started steamrolling back and I was under that. Wow. Mm-hmm. I was under that. Well, it's crazy because I remember that we practiced that forever. And I kind of remember it because all I do is sit at the reception desk and I had thought
这样他们能更好地看到你。这样他们能更好地看到我们。这样他们能更好地看到我们。当然。所以他们让我们出来，但莱斯利没想过他会摔倒。他在任何排练中都没有摔倒。他没有被推得那么用力。是的，好吧，他还没被雷恩·威尔逊推。不，他没有。
to myself, did I need to be here for the two hours? That's what I thought. That's what I thought. That's what I thought. They said, you know, definitely they didn't want me seated at my desk. They wanted me to come out a little bit to the edge of accounting. Sometimes they would have us do that. If there's a scene in the main office bullpen and they want to get reaction shots of everyone, they would kind of have Kevin and my character come out.
所以莱斯利飞了出去，撞到了我，然后滚到了我身上。拍摄结束后，每个人都说，哦，天哪，克里德，你还好吗？克里德。然后他们说，哦，BJ，你还好吗？然后他们说，哦，天哪，莱斯利。因为莱斯利确实摔得很重。他们说，莱斯利，你还好吗？
So they could see you better. So they could see us better. So they could see us better. Of course. And so they had us come out, but Leslie did not think he was going to fall. He did not fall in any of the rehearsals. He wasn't shoved that hard. Yeah, well, he wasn't being shoved by Rainn Wilson yet. No, he wasn't.
他们把莱斯利拉起来。奥斯卡说，哦，天哪，安吉拉。奥斯卡是唯一看到我的人。我说，是的。然后我不知道你是否注意到，但这一切都发生在第一分钟。如果你看时间码。现在去1分05秒。
So Leslie went flying and collided into me and then rolled backwards on top of me. And after the take, everyone was like, oh my God, Creed, are you okay? Creed. And then they were like, oh, BJ, are you okay? And then they're like, oh my God, Leslie. Cause Leslie really went down hard. They're like, Leslie, are you okay?
莱斯利不在那里了。哦，就像他被拍了，他只拍了第一条吗？我不知道，珍娜，它是怎么发生的，但我认为他被撞倒了，然后站起来说，不。好吧，我不知道你是否注意到在20秒时，当迈克尔扔球并撞倒吉姆桌上的东西时，
They pulled Leslie up. And Oscar goes, oh my God, Angela. Oscar was like the only person that saw me. I was like, yeah. And then I don't know if you notice, but all of this happens at one minute. If you look at the time code. Now go to one minute, five seconds.
它们都向前掉到了德怀特桌子前的一堆盒子上。如果你看42秒，迈克尔把球扔给奥斯卡，所有那些盒子都不见了。它们被清理了，没有放回去。哦，看看我们。小小的连续性发现。背景里的小发现。我确实想向里安娜·罗耶致意，她写信问橄榄球投掷是否是计划好的。所以我们回答了那个问题，但我确实感谢你的来信。是的，不，那都是计划好的。
Leslie is no longer there. Oh, like he was take, did he only do the first take? I don't know, Jenna, how it went down, but I think he got knocked down and then got up and was like, nope. Well, I don't know if you notice at 20 seconds when Michael tosses the ball and he knocks over Jim's stuff on his desk,
虽然莱斯利的。那部分不是计划好的。安吉拉被压扁不是计划好的。好吧，现在我们继续。德怀特坐在他的桌子旁，他在谈论，哦，TiVo的促销。他要为自己买点特别的东西，因为他是年度最佳销售员。等等，这是一个旧技术警报。TiVo。TiVo。
it all kind of falls forward onto this pile of boxes that's in front of Dwight's desk. If you look at 42 seconds, Michael tosses the ball to Oscar and all those boxes are missing. They were cleared and not returned. Oh, look at us. Little continuity catch. Little catches there in the background. I did want to throw out to Rihanna Royer, who had written in to ask if the football toss was planned. And so we answered that question, but I do thank you for writing in. Yes, no, that was all planned.
他谈到了CD刻录机。我们还发现吉姆得了第九名。第九。他得到的只有Cagino's披萨。是的。但是伙计们，你们有人有TiVo吗？你有TiVo吗？我有一个TiVo。
Although Leslie's. That part wasn't planned. Angela's getting squashed was not planned. All right, so now we move on. Dwight is sitting at his desk and he is talking about, oh, a sale on TiVo. He's gonna buy something special for himself because he is salesperson of the year. Hold up, this is an old tech alert though. TiVo. TiVo.
是的。好吧，年轻人，TiVo就像录像机。它就像最早的数字视频录制设备之一，你可以录制你的节目。是的，它和你现在DirecTV或有线电视上的东西一样。但我们没有那个。我们没有那个。
He talks about a CD burner. We also find out that Jim came in ninth place. Ninth. And all he's getting is Cagino's pizza. Yeah. But you guys, do any of you have TiVo's? Did you have a TiVo? I had a TiVo.
你必须把它连接到你的有线电视盒上。那是如果你有VHS播放器，你可以录制你的有线电视节目的日子。但我们没有那个。我们没有那个。你必须把它连接到你的有线电视盒上。那是如果你有VHS播放器，你可以录制你的节目。但像这个改变了它，因为它数字化地录制了东西，你可以计划你的录制。你不需要跑回家按下录制按钮。我觉得这就像我妈妈试图告诉我没有微波炉的生活是什么样的。我说，我不在乎。我只想加热一些汤。TiVo是一个游戏规则改变者。确实是。我很高兴有TiVo。
Yeah. OK, young people, TiVo was like a VCR. It was like one of the very first digital video recordings where you could record your show. Yeah, it's the same as what you have now on your DirecTV or your cable. But we didn't have that. We didn't have that.
2004年2月有一个时刻，TiVo拥有TiVo历史上观看、录制和重播次数最多的时刻。那是什么？是珍妮特·杰克逊的超级碗，与贾斯汀·汀布莱克的半场秀？胸部走光。她的胸部露出来的那个。
You had to hook it into your cable box. These were the days where if you had a VHS player, you could record one of your cable. But we didn't have that. We didn't have that. You had to hook it into your cable box. These were the days where like if you had a VHS player, you could record one of your shows. But like this changed it because it digitally recorded things and you could like plan out your records. You didn't have to like run home and hit the record button. I feel like this is like my mom trying to tell me about what life was like without a microwave. I'm like, I don't care. I just want to heat up some soup. Tevo was a game changer. It was. I was so excited to have Tevo.
是的。那是TiVo历史上观看、录制和重播次数最多的时刻。TiVo的人说观众反应图看起来像心电图。哦，天哪。就像，突突突突突突。我的意思是。
There was one moment in February of 2004 that Tevo had the most watch recorded and replayed moment in Tevo history. What was it? It was Janet Jackson's Super Bowl, halftime with Justin Timberlake? The boob slip. Where her boob came out.
那太疯狂了。那太疯狂了。所以你知道当吉姆说他只赢了一个Cogino's披萨时？是的。这是吉姆第二次提到Cogino's。他在《客户》的一段删减片段中也提到了它，他说他最糟糕的第一次约会发生在Cogino's披萨店。这是一家真正的意大利餐厅。它在邓莫尔，就在斯克兰顿外面。它实际上
Yes. That was the most watched, recorded, and replayed moment in TiVo history. The folks at TiVo said the audience reaction charts looked like an electrocardiogram. Oh my god. It was like, chug-a-chug-a-chug-a-chug-a-chug-a-chug. I mean.
在邓莫尔的东德林克街107号。他们确实供应披萨，但我找不到他们的网站或在线菜单。但是伙计们，这是一个小型的家族企业，Cagino's披萨。把它放在你的《办公室》之旅中，因为当我在为这一集查找东西时，我发现了这些网站，你可以进行某种小型的旅行度假，在那里你可以打卡《办公室》的所有站点。是的。所以去Cugino's吃点披萨吧。伙计们，我想在2分31秒向你们展示一个完整的绕口令。
That is crazy. That is crazy. So you know when Jim says he just wins a Cogino's Pizza? Yes. This is the second time Jim has mentioned Cogino's. He also brought it up in a deleted scene from The Client where he says his worst first date took place at Cogino's Pizza. This is a real Italian restaurant. It is in Dunmore, right outside of Scranton. It's actually
好吧。准备好了吗？是的。我想要你们，萨姆，醒醒。我想要你们试着快速说这个10遍。好吧，准备好了吗？是的。这简直是最高荣誉
at 107 East Drinker Street in Dunmore. They do serve pizza, but I could not find a website for them or an online menu. But guys, it's a little family-owned business, Cagino's Pizza. Put it on your The Office Tour, because when I was looking up stuff for this episode, I found these websites that you can do sort of like a little travel vacation where you hit all the stops of the office. Yeah. So go get some pizza at Cugino's. Guys, I want to present to you at two minutes, 31 seconds a complete tongue twister.
一个东北宾夕法尼亚州的中型造纸公司区域销售员能获得的。怎么？哦，那是来自吉姆的采访。是的。但是——他是怎么记住那个的？但他怎么能把它全部放在一句话里？那不容易。
Okay. Ready? Yeah. I want you guys, Sam, wake up in there. I want you guys to try to say this 10 times fast. Okay, ready? Yeah. It is literally the highest possible honor
那不容易。好吧，掌声，约翰。干得好，约翰·卡拉辛斯基。吉姆绕口令。好吧，我们到哪了？好吧，说到吉姆，我们终于在厨房里和吉姆与帕姆在一起了，他们终于像往常一样开玩笑了。
that a Northeastern Pennsylvania based midsize paper company regional salesman can attain. How? Oh, that's from Jim's talking head. Yes. But like- How did he memorize that? But how did he get it all in like one sentence? That is not easy.
一位宾夕法尼亚州东北部的中型造纸公司区域销售员所能达到的成就。怎么做到的？哦，那是吉姆的访谈片段。没错。但是，他是怎么背下来的？他怎么能把这一切浓缩成一句话的？这可不容易。
That is not easy. All right, applause, John. Well done, John Krasinski. Jim tongue twister. Okay, where are we at? Well, speaking of Jim, we are finally in the kitchen with Jim and Pam, and they are finally bantering again like old times.
这确实不容易。好了，鼓掌吧，约翰。干得好，约翰·卡拉辛斯基。吉姆的绕口令。好吧，我们讲到哪了？说到吉姆，我们终于和吉姆与帕姆一起在厨房了，他们终于又像往常一样打趣了。
They're flirting. Ah, they're so cute. Nice little back and forth. There's been this drought. They've been a bit estranged, and it looks like things are gonna thaw until Phyllis comes out of the bathroom and asks Pam about her wedding dress.
他们在调情。啊，他们太可爱了。真是一段美好的互动。之前一直处于冷战期。他们之间有点疏远，看起来关系要缓和了，直到菲利斯从洗手间出来，问帕姆关于她婚纱的事。
Oh, awkward. And Jim makes kind of a quick exit. At 2 minutes 40 seconds, there's a shot of Jim's coffee mug. And it says, quote, together we build a better Scranton, restoring the pride. And Dunderpedia pointed out that this was the motto of a downtown Scranton revitalization project. And you will see Jim use this mug
哦，尴尬。吉姆很快就离开了。在2分40秒时，有一个吉姆咖啡杯的特写。上面写着：“齐心协力建设更美好的斯克兰顿，重塑自豪感”。Dunderpedia指出，这是斯克兰顿市中心振兴项目的口号。你会看到吉姆在整集中都在用这个杯子。
throughout the entire episode. Way to go. That's Phil Shea putting some local props in play. But also good catches there. Yeah, local pizza place, local mug. So now we go to Pam's talking head and she says, listen, I just, I have to do my wedding planning at the office, you know, but it can get weird sometimes and she's worried about people getting offended like Angela.
干得好。那是菲尔·谢（Phil Shea）在布置当地的道具。不过这些细节抓得真好。没错，当地的披萨店，当地的杯子。现在镜头转到帕姆的采访，她说，听着，我只是，我必须在办公室里筹备婚礼，你知道，但这有时会变得很奇怪，她担心人们会感到被冒犯，比如安吉拉。
Look what I wrote on my card. What? Leave me out of it. Leave me out of it. This has nothing to do with me and your scandalous emotional affair you're having. Leave me out of it. All right, so now Dwight is feeding himself grapes at his desk and Michael enters and says,
看看我在卡片上写了什么。什么？别把我扯进去。别把我扯进去。这和我以及你那场丑闻般的感情纠葛毫无关系。别把我扯进去。好了，现在德怀特在办公桌前吃葡萄，迈克尔走进来，说了句：
that's what she said, because grapes, seductive. And he asked Dwight if he's ready for his big speech. Well, I have real beef with Michael on this episode. Talk to me about it. He does not want Dwight to succeed. He doesn't. He is flat out mean to him. He's psych want Dwight to succeed. He doesn't. He is flat out mean to him. He's psyching him out.
“那是她说的”，因为葡萄，很诱人。他问德怀特是否准备好他的重要演讲了。好吧，这一集里我对迈克尔有很大的意见。跟我说说。他根本不想让德怀特成功。他真的不想。他对德怀特简直太刻薄了。他在打击他的信心。
Yeah. He's negative. He's putting him down the whole episode. So Angela, the Angela Martin in me, is like, you're not being nice. No. Then Jim goes on to sabotage Dwight. Like, why?
是的。他很消极。他整集都在贬低他。所以安吉拉，我内心里的安吉拉·马丁觉得，你这样一点都不友好。没错。然后吉姆去破坏德怀特的演讲。为什么？
Why is everyone coming down on Dwight? Well. Is it because he's a little bit rubbing it in everyone's face? I think Jim had motivation because Dwight's rubbing it in his face. That's fine. They have that back and forth. But Dwight just adores Michael
为什么每个人都要针对德怀特？嗯。是因为他有点在大家面前炫耀吗？我觉得吉姆有动机，因为德怀特在他面前炫耀。那没关系。他们有那种互动。但德怀特非常崇拜迈克尔，
and hangs on his every word and isn't rubbing it in his face. Michael is just, I think, jealous that someone else has the spotlight. He's like a little bratty kid. He also puts himself in this position of expert. So he's got this talking head now where he explains that he won salesman of the year
对他言听计从，并没有在他面前炫耀。迈克尔只是，我觉得，嫉妒别人抢了风头。他就像个任性的小孩。他还把自己放在专家的位置上。所以他现在有个采访，解释说他之前连续两次获得年度最佳销售员。
twice before consecutively. I know. Twice in a row. But one year he got a plaque, the other year he just got a certificate. Well, they stopped making plaques. Right. Can we talk about where this talking head takes place?
我知道。连续两次。但有一年他拿到了奖牌，另一年他只拿到了一张证书。好吧，他们不再制作奖牌了。没错。我们能谈谈这个采访是在哪里进行的吗？
In his cabinet. Inside his, like, man armoire. Yes, in his office. Yes, at four minutes, one second, you get a really good shot of it. Did you look and see what all's inside? You know I did. You know you did.
在他的柜子里。在他那个像衣柜一样的储物柜里。是的，在他的办公室里。是的，在4分01秒，你有一个非常好的特写。你看了里面都有什么吗？你知道我看了。你知道你看了。
OK, let's trade some stuff. Break it down. Is that Jan on the cover of the Dunder Mifflin newsletter? Yeah, did you see that her name is still listed as Gould? Oh. So how long has that been there? He saved it for a bit. It's pre-Gould.
好吧，我们来交换一下信息。拆解一下。那是简在邓德·米夫林通讯的封面上吗？是的，你看到她的名字还是列为古尔德（Gould）吗？哦。那这放了多久了？他存了一阵子。那是古尔德之前的事。
Okay, he's got a mirror, he's got a mini fridge, but on the top shelf of his mini fridge is a fancy silver tea set. Yeah, it's not a mini fridge, that's a safe. That's a safe. He has a safe that he has gotten his plaque and certificate out of. And then the top shelf of the safe, there is a tea set.
好吧，他有一个镜子，一个迷你冰箱，但在迷你冰箱的顶层有一个精致的银色茶具。是的，那不是迷你冰箱，那是保险箱。那是保险箱。他有一个保险箱，他把奖牌和证书从里面拿了出来。然后保险箱的顶层，有一个茶具。
This makes a lot more sense. I mean, kind of, it's still strange. I was like, why is he refrigerating this? Why is he chilling the whole tea set? Yeah, like why is this? And then also why is he chosen to chill a plaque? But they hung two other plaques. They're not worthy of the mini fridge, safe.
这下说得通多了。我是说，某种程度上，还是很奇怪。我当时想，他为什么要冷藏这个？为什么要冷藏整套茶具？是的，为什么会这样？还有他为什么要冷藏一个奖牌？但他们挂了另外两个奖牌。它们不配进迷你冰箱保险箱。
Well, he also has Pepto Bismol deodorant, toothbrush and toothpaste, and a can of something. A can of something, and then what are those two squares? What, like a couple of items, like wrapped in mesh? It looked like it. With some twine? It looked like it. We don't know. We don't know. It was weird.
好吧，他还有胃药、除臭剂、牙刷和牙膏，以及一罐什么东西。一罐什么东西，还有那两个方块是什么？什么，像是一些用网包裹的东西？看起来像。还有绳子？看起来像。我们不知道。我们不知道。这很奇怪。
He had a change of clothes, a dundee, two mounted plaques. It looked like maybe a silver shot glass and a blue cup. There you go, Michael's credenza. Mini fridge. Which is a safe. I really need to start watching these episodes with my glasses on. Clearly.
他有一套换洗衣服，一个邓迪奖杯，两个挂着的奖牌。看起来可能是一个银色的小酒杯和一个蓝色杯子。就是这样，迈克尔的餐具柜。迷你冰箱。其实是个保险箱。我真的需要戴上眼镜看这些剧集了。显然。
Clearly. Look at that mini fridge. It's a safe Angela. Guys, at four minutes, 23 seconds, Dwight has this great talking head where he talks about losing his sixth grade spelling beat for not being able to spell the word failure. That was an improvisation. Rain improvised that part of it, that the word was failure. That is fantastic, Rain.
显然。看看那个迷你冰箱。那是保险箱，安吉拉。伙计们，在4分23秒，德怀特有一个很棒的采访，他谈到因为拼不出“失败”（failure）这个词而输掉了六年级的拼写比赛。那是即兴表演。雷恩即兴发挥了那部分，那个词是“失败”。太棒了，雷恩。
That's good. I think you can really start hearing that he's sick, and that talking head. And then later in the conference room scenes, I really heard it. OK, so you know the scene in Michael's office where he's telling Dwight, I'm going to mentor you. I can teach you enough so you don't embarrass yourself
那很好。我觉得你真的能开始听出他生病了，在那个采访里。后来在会议室的场景里，我真的听出来了。好吧，你知道迈克尔办公室里的那个场景，他告诉德怀特，我要指导你。我可以教你足够多的东西，这样你就不会在演讲中让自己出丑。
during this speech. If you look in the background over Rain's shoulder and you can see reception in the background and it's me and Kate and we're back there. And here is something that's very interesting. Whenever I did background work with Kate, we stayed in character the whole time. You can see us crouching over Pam's computer, and we did a whole runner about our frustration
如果你看雷恩肩膀后面的背景，你可以看到背景里的接待处，是我和凯特，我们在那里。这里有一件非常有趣的事情。每当我和凯特做背景表演时，我们全程都保持角色状态。你可以看到我们蹲在帕姆的电脑前，我们编了一整段关于我们对新电脑系统感到沮丧的戏，
with the new computer system that won't allow us to enter both alpha and numeric codes into the sales orders, and that it was a huge problem. And I wrote about it in my diary, and I said that we stayed in character the entire two hours that they shot in Michael's office. By the way, that's the smartest Meredith was written in the whole series. Was in our background improvisations.
它不允许我们在销售订单中输入字母和数字代码，这是一个巨大的问题。我在日记里写过这件事，我说我们在迈克尔办公室拍摄的那两个小时里，全程都保持着角色状态。顺便说一句，那是整部剧里梅雷迪思被写得最聪明的一次。就是在我们的背景即兴表演中。
Yeah. That's the most competent Meredith has ever sounded. They were the most fun to me. We always had the best time, Kate and I, because we would come up with these, it was always something we were annoyed with. It was always some new office procedure. And we would kind of complain about it and try to figure it out.
是的。那是梅雷迪思听起来最能干的一次。对我来说，那些是最有趣的。我和凯特总是玩得很开心，因为我们会想出这些点子，总是关于一些让我们恼火的事情。总是关于一些新的办公程序。我们会抱怨它，并试图弄清楚它。
Yeah. Oscar and I would do bits like that. We would totally stay in character. But what we were talking about would be absolutely ridiculous. He would very seriously pass me papers, important payroll papers, but he would have attached a post-it note that would say, will you please file these in your butt? And then he would draw a little cartoon with it, and it always cracked me up. Well, I just thought it was really sweet because I, you know, we go back to our diaries and
是的。奥斯卡和我也会做那样的片段。我们完全保持角色状态。但我们谈论的内容会非常荒谬。他会非常严肃地递给我文件，重要的工资单文件，但他会贴上一张便条，上面写着：“请把这些文件塞进你的屁股里好吗？”然后他会画一个小卡通，这总是让我笑个不停。好吧，我只是觉得这真的很甜，因为我，你知道，我们回到我们的日记里，
we read what we wrote and I had written all about how much fun I had on this episode filming with Kate in the background of that scene. That's so cute. I love that. I know. All right. So next we cut to Pam's desk and she is on the phone with her mom and she says, Mom, I don't, I know you guys are paying for the wedding,
我们读我们写的东西，我写了很多关于我在这一集里和凯特在背景中拍摄有多开心。太可爱了。我喜欢那个。我知道。好了。所以接下来镜头切到帕姆的桌子，她正在和她妈妈通电话，她说，妈，我不知道，我知道你们在付婚礼的钱，
but I don't want orange invitation. Orange invitation. Orange invitation, Pam's mom. I mean, you know I've had some frustrations with Pam's mom. What is happening? Add that to the list. Why are you getting married? Orange.
但我不想用橙色的请柬。橙色请柬。橙色请柬，帕姆的妈妈。我是说，你知道我对帕姆的妈妈有些不满。发生了什么？把它加到名单里。你为什么要结婚？橙色。
I know. Orange. I mean, crazy. Pam, you know, her wedding color is lavender, by the way. It's not orange. I wrote that in my diary. That's not even revealed in this episode. Pam's wedding color.
我知道。橙色。我是说，太疯狂了。帕姆，你知道，她的婚礼颜色是薰衣草色，顺便说一下。不是橙色。我在日记里写了。这一集里甚至都没透露。帕姆的婚礼颜色。
I wrote it down in my journal. And I was curious if that was true or if it was a character choice. And I went and I looked at the wedding photos and all my bridesmaids are in lavender. Yeah, no. That, yeah. And when I think about it, I think I have a memory of Phil Shea giving me something that had lavender on it,
我把它写在我的日记里了。我很好奇那是真的还是角色的选择。我去看了婚礼照片，我所有的伴娘都穿着薰衣草色。是的，没错。当我想到它时，我想我记得菲尔·谢给了我一些带有薰衣草色的东西，
like the Save the Date card had a little lavender ribbon or something. And so it was picked for me, I didn't pick it. But it was in your brain. It was in my brain. Well, you know, poor Jim overhears this and he's like, that's it. I'm out. He's calling a travel agent.
比如“保存日期”卡片上有一条小薰衣草丝带之类的。所以它是为我选的，不是我选的。但它在你的脑海里。它在我的脑海里。好吧，你知道，可怜的吉姆听到了这些，他想，就是这样。我受够了。他要给旅行社打电话。
I'm going on a trip. This sort of dates our show a little bit too because I know travel agents are still out there, but a lot of people now just go online. Yeah. Although I did use a travel agent recently for a trip and it was very helpful. I did too.
我要去旅行了。这让我们的剧集显得有点过时了，因为我知道旅行社仍然存在，但现在很多人只是上网。是的。虽然我最近确实为一次旅行用了旅行社，而且非常有帮助。我也用了。
I did too when I went to Europe, but I did, you know, we did a lot of it just online. Yeah. Yeah. You can't, well, now you can compare airline prices online using Expedia or Orbit. Not getting paid to say that. Not getting paid. So now we're going to really clock into this thermostat war. It seems to mainly be between Angela and Oscar.
我去欧洲时也用了，但我确实，你知道，我们大部分都是在网上完成的。是的。是的。你不能，好吧，现在你可以在网上使用Expedia或Orbit比较机票价格。没收钱说这个。没收钱。所以现在我们要真正进入这个恒温器战争了。这似乎主要是安吉拉和奥斯卡之间的事。
Oscar says that he purposely gets to work early to set the thermostat at 66 degrees. What a sneaky sneak. 66. 66. I just need everyone to clock a little bit of my Angela Martin look, because this is the first time you see me kind of nice and close up. Do I look tan?
奥斯卡说他故意早点上班，把恒温器调到66度。真是个鬼鬼祟祟的人。66。66。我只是需要每个人都注意一下我的安吉拉·马丁造型，因为这是你第一次看到我这么近距离。我看起来晒黑了吗？
Because I'm tan. Are you still tan? I'm still tan. This mystic tan that lasted like three weeks. You guys, I'm so tan in this episode. Also, Kim Ferry outdid herself with this really intricate braid. That's all my actual hair.
因为我晒黑了。你还在晒黑吗？我还在晒黑。这种持续了大约三周的神秘美黑。伙计们，我在这一集里晒得太黑了。还有，金·费里（Kim Ferry）用这个非常复杂的辫子超越了自己。那全是我真实的头发。
Look at the back, it's like a bun, but it's like a braid that goes like zigzags back and forth. So she's really, she really went for it. In the cold open, I have a different outfit on, different hair. Different look. Different look, different day. Different day. But in the main episode of Dwight's speech,
看看后面，它像个发髻，但它像是一个来回曲折的辫子。所以她真的，她真的拼了。在冷开场里，我穿了不同的衣服，不同的发型。不同的造型。不同的日子。不同的日子。但在德怀特演讲的主剧集中，
I'm incredibly tan and I have this fantastic Kim Ferry braid. Well, we had a fan question from David Hurtweck. What was the actual temperature in the office area when we were filming? Freezing. Probably like. 65. I was going to say 64, 65 degrees.
我晒得非常黑，而且我有这个很棒的金·费里辫子。好吧，我们有一个来自大卫·赫特韦克（David Hurtweck）的粉丝提问。我们拍摄时办公区的实际温度是多少？冷得要命。大概像。65度。我本来想说64、65度。
Yeah. It was very, very cold. We kept it very, very cold, mostly for Steve, who runs hot, and he would have to wear the suits. And I mean, all the guys actually were always in suits. And the lights do warm up the stage, but they cranked the air down so the guys wouldn't get sweaty in their suits.
是的。非常非常冷。我们保持得非常非常冷，主要是为了史蒂夫，他怕热，他必须穿西装。我是说，所有的男士其实总是穿西装。灯光确实会让舞台变暖，但他们把空调开得很大，这样男士们就不会在西装里出汗。
But the gals were in these little silk blouses and skirts and we all froze. Yeah. So I would wear Ugg boots under my desk. We all had little heaters. I sometimes even had a blanket over my legs. I had a blanket and a heater and I would like sit at my desk, like huddled under my desk trying to stay warm. All right. So now we move into the conference room and Michael is ready to start giving Dwight
但女士们穿着这些丝绸衬衫和裙子，我们都冻僵了。是的。所以我会在桌子底下穿UGG靴子。我们都有小加热器。我有时甚至会在腿上盖一条毯子。我有一条毯子和一个加热器，我会坐在桌子旁，蜷缩在桌子底下试图保持温暖。好了。所以现在我们进入会议室，迈克尔准备开始给德怀特
some speech training. Yes. He says, what is the difference between a salesman and a saleswoman? Vagina. Vagina. And Michael is like, oh, yes, congratulations, Dwight. That's the difference between a man and a woman. I love Dwight goes, but I'm right. Yeah, but I'm right. Right. But then Michael says, no, the difference is boobs. That's what he wants him to open his speech with. It makes you wonder how Michael's speech went those two years in a row.
一些演讲训练。是的。他说，推销员和推销员有什么区别？阴道。阴道。迈克尔说，哦，是的，恭喜你，德怀特。这就是男人和女人的区别。我喜欢德怀特说，但我说得对。是的，但我说得对。没错。但迈克尔说，不，区别是胸部。这就是他想让他演讲开场白用的。这让你想知道迈克尔那连续两年演讲是怎么进行的。
How it really went. How it really went. Yeah. Because Dwight says, can I just have a copy of your speech? And Michael's like, no, no, they'd remember. It's legendary. I couldn't possibly let you read parts of my speech. It killed.
它是怎么进行的。它是怎么进行的。是的。因为德怀特说，我能有一份你的演讲稿吗？迈克尔说，不，不，他们会记得的。这是传奇。我不可能让你读我演讲稿的部分。它太成功了。
It killed. And then Michael gives Dwight some advice. He's like, it doesn't really matter what you say as long as people care about what you're saying. And he's going to show him an example of that. Yes, please tell us the example. OK, well he runs out to the bullpen and he says that they had done so well this quarter
它太成功了。然后迈克尔给了德怀特一些建议。他说，你说什么并不重要，只要人们关心你在说什么就行。他要给他展示一个例子。是的，请告诉我们这个例子。好吧，他跑到办公区，说他们这个季度做得非常好，
that corporate is going to give everyone a $1,000 bonus. Everyone. Everyone. I mean, people are thrilled. It's so excited. Stanley gets right on the phone and tells his wife to order the new curtains. The wallpaper.
公司要给每个人发1000美元的奖金。每个人。每个人。我是说，人们都很激动。太兴奋了。斯坦利立刻打电话告诉他妻子去订新的窗帘。壁纸。
Oh, it's wallpaper. Yes. He's like, go ahead, wallpaper the new curtains. The wallpaper. Oh, it's wallpaper. Yes. Yeah. He's like, go ahead, wallpaper the ceiling if you want to. Oh, amazing. So they go back into the conference room and Dwight's like, oh my God, that's amazing. And Michael's like, what? It's not true.
哦，是壁纸。是的。他说，去吧，给新窗帘贴上壁纸。壁纸。哦，是壁纸。是的。是的。他说，去吧，如果你想的话，给天花板贴上壁纸。哦，太棒了。所以他们回到会议室，德怀特说，天哪，太棒了。迈克尔说，什么？那不是真的。
I was just talking. But in that moment, I had him. I had him. I had him. Oh my God. So Dwight tries it. Dwight goes out into the bullpen. This is so funny.
我只是随便说说。但在那一刻，我抓住了他。我抓住了他。我抓住了他。天哪。所以德怀特试了一下。德怀特走到办公区。这太搞笑了。
This scene made me laugh so hard. So hard. It made me laugh on the day. I remember shooting this. The thing that made me laugh on the day is Kelly's line, but I'll get to that. Yeah. You mean just Mindy. Mindy.
这个场景让我笑得太厉害了。太厉害了。我在拍摄当天就笑得不行。让我笑的是凯利的台词，但我稍后会讲到。是的。你是说敏迪。敏迪。
We still have full Mindy. Mindy. We still have full Mindy. Dwight announces that there has been a major car accident on the interstate, major. Car slid off the road into the railing. People were injured. Terrible. And Pam says, did we know anyone in the accident? And he says, Brad Pitt.
我们还有完整的敏迪。敏迪。我们还有完整的敏迪。德怀特宣布州际公路上发生了一起重大车祸，重大。车滑出路面撞上护栏。有人受伤。太可怕了。帕姆说，我们认识车祸里的人吗？他说，布拉德·皮特。
Brad Pitt. And Mindy asks, did he die? And he's like, he'll never act again. No, but he'll never act again. And then he goes, Oh, also, there's no bonuses. And the branch is closing. And then she's like, this is because of Jen Aniston. It's karma. And we're like, wait, and we're like, are we out of jobs? Like, what is happening? Insane. I remember that. I remember shooting on that day. That was a really hard one to get through,
布拉德·皮特。敏迪问，他死了吗？他说，他再也不会演戏了。不，但他再也不会演戏了。然后他说，哦，还有，没有奖金了。分部要关闭了。然后她说，这是因为詹妮弗·安妮斯顿。这是因果报应。我们就像，等等，我们就像，我们失业了吗？发生了什么？太疯狂了。我记得那个。我记得那天拍摄。那是一个很难坚持下去的场景，
and it was a complete joy to watch. All right, so Michael says, everybody go in the conference room. Just go in the conference room. He's going to teach everyone how to give a speech. Pam says, Pam has a sign, like Toastmasters. And Michael says, Pam, I'm public speaking. Stop public interrupting me.
看的时候完全是一种享受。好了，迈克尔说，大家去会议室。去会议室。他要教大家怎么演讲。帕姆说，帕姆有一个标志，像国际演讲会。迈克尔说，帕姆，我在公开演讲。停止公开打断我。
I don't think that's a GIF, but it should be. I did a search to see if there is a GIF of someone of Michael saying, I'm public speaking. Stop public interrupting me. Am I wrong? Am I wrong? There's also a deleted scene.
我不认为那是个GIF，但它应该是。我搜索了一下看有没有迈克尔说“我在公开演讲，停止公开打断我”的GIF。我错了吗？我错了吗？还有一个删除的场景。
Please, you guys, if you have a chance. Phyllis stands up in the conference room and sort of shares and it is absolutely amazing. What does she share? I remember she had a hard time getting through it. What is it? Because we were cracking up. She starts, it's she, you know, Michael wants everyone to get up and sort of say a toast. Yeah. Phyllis gets up and she's like, well, you know, I'm having one of the best years of my life. I'm in a relationship, I've met a nice person and I really thought that that part of my life was over
拜托，伙计们，如果有机会的话。菲利斯在会议室站起来分享，这绝对太棒了。她分享了什么？我记得她很难坚持下去。是什么？因为我们笑得前仰后合。她开始，是她，你知道，迈克尔想让每个人都站起来祝酒。是的。菲利斯站起来说，嗯，你知道，我正在经历我一生中最好的几年之一。我在谈恋爱，我遇到了一个好人，我真的以为我生命中的那部分已经结束了
for me, that that wasn't gonna happen. And I'm not gonna lie, I've had some really dark thoughts. And she goes down this road and Michael's like, and really, really just brings the room totally down, but really earnest and Michael's like, Oh, okay. All right. Just sit down. Well, Jim gets up in the conference room and announces he's going on a trip and he would like some suggestions on where to go. So Kevin suggests he go to hedonism. He says it's like Club Med, but everything is naked. I did not Google that. I didn't want to know. Did you?
对我来说，那不会发生了。我不会撒谎，我有一些非常黑暗的想法。她沿着这条路走下去，迈克尔说，真的，真的让房间气氛完全低落，但非常真诚，迈克尔说，哦，好吧。好吧。坐下吧。好吧，吉姆在会议室站起来宣布他要去旅行，他想听听去哪里的建议。所以凯文建议他去享乐主义度假村。他说那就像地中海俱乐部，但一切都是裸体的。我没有谷歌搜索那个。我不想知道。你搜了吗？
I did. Oh my God. I did. You did? I did. Is it a real thing? It is a real resort in Jamaica. And everyone's naked?
我搜了。天哪。我搜了。你搜了？我搜了。那是真的吗？那是牙买加的一个真实度假村。每个人都裸体？
is a real resort in Jamaica. And everyone's naked? Yep. Well, OK. Their website describes it as, quote, a lifestyle-friendly clothing-optional resort. Also described as the sexiest place on Earth where you can be as mild or wild as you like. What does that mean?
是牙买加的一个真实度假村。每个人都裸体？是的。好吧，OK。他们的网站将其描述为，引用，“一个生活方式友好、服装可选的度假村”。也被描述为地球上最性感的地方，在那里你可以随心所欲地温和或狂野。那是什么意思？
OK, so here's the deal. I really looked into it. So there are clothing optional sections of the resort and then there are nude sections. So like you could be going down the buffet. That you cannot do. Like getting your pancakes, scrambled eggs. No, for health reasons you must wear a cover up in the lobby and around food. Well thank you for that. But if you're in the nude pool or the nude beach, you have to be nude. But if you're in the clothing optional part, you can wear sort of the suggestion is like, you know, go sexy.
好吧，是这样的。我真的研究了一下。度假村里有服装可选区，还有裸体区。所以你可以去自助餐厅。你不能那样做。比如拿煎饼、炒蛋。不，出于健康原因，你在大厅和食物周围必须穿遮盖物。好吧，谢谢你告诉我。但如果你在裸体泳池或裸体海滩，你必须裸体。但如果你在服装可选区，你可以穿，建议是，你知道，走性感路线。
You wear a little something. But here was one thing I found interesting. If you enter a nude area, you've got a 10-minute grace period to disrobe. And they're like... Then you got to get out. You're not here to look-see-look-see. That's right. We're going to give you 10 minutes to take off your stuff, but there's more. You thought there wasn't, but there is. No, I actually figured you had something else coming. I'm cringing. I'm waiting.
你穿一点点东西。但我发现有一件事很有趣。如果你进入裸体区，你有10分钟的宽限期脱衣服。他们说……然后你得离开。你不是来这里看来看去的。没错。我们要给你10分钟脱掉你的东西，但还有更多。你以为没有，但确实有。不，我其实猜到你还有别的话要说。我感到尴尬。我在等。
They have a playroom. Oh god. For couples, single women and invited single men. Oh lord. It's open from 10 30 p.m. to 3 a.m. You go wrestle with your friends. I don't know. Most people who stay at the resorts are couples, but they do have single person rates available. A few more facts. There is no tipping allowed. Who are you tipping? Your wait staff, but it's all inclusive. Oh, okay. So I mean, I think that that is an important thing to know
他们有一个游戏室。哦，天哪。为情侣、单身女性和受邀的单身男性准备的。哦，天哪。它从晚上10点30分开放到凌晨3点。你去和你的朋友摔跤。我不知道。大多数住在度假村的人是情侣，但他们确实有单人价格。还有几个事实。不允许给小费。你给谁小费？服务员，但这是全包的。哦，好吧。所以我是说，我认为这是一个重要的事情，
because where would you put the money? Oh. You're naked. You're naked. So don't let it stress you out. There's no tipping allowed. Yeah. Don't worry about where you're carrying the extra cash. Yeah.
因为你会把钱放在哪里？哦。你裸体。你裸体。所以不要让它让你感到压力。不允许给小费。是的。不要担心你带着多余的现金。是的。
Not a problem. One of the frequently asked questions is, are there irons and ironing boards? For what? I don't know, but the answer is yes. So yes, they do have irons and ironing boards. So also you can renew your vows there. Okay. All right. Toby suggests that Jim go to Amsterdam. He says he went there after his divorce for a week or maybe a month. He can't remember. Toby. Creed says he should go to Hong Kong.
没问题。常见问题之一是，有熨斗和熨衣板吗？为了什么？我不知道，但答案是肯定的。所以是的，他们确实有熨斗和熨衣板。所以你也可以在那里重温誓言。好吧。好吧。托比建议吉姆去阿姆斯特丹。他说他在离婚后去那里待了一周或一个月。他不记得了。托比。克里德说他应该去香港。
Creed also calls John Jimmy, and I feel like you can see John about to break. He's like, Jimmy. And I swear John has this like, he's kind of got this side smile. Well, at nine minutes, 29 seconds, Creed has a talking head. For anyone wondering, Creed is speaking Mandarin. Yeah. And he says, Hello, my Chinese friends. That's what he's saying in Mandarin. I reached out to Creed. Yeah. Because we had a fan question from KKPL Watson. He said, at various times Creed has spoken Japanese and Chinese on the show. Does he really speak either? So I texted Creed. Oh, I can't wait. What was his response? Here's what he said. Did he say, who are you? No. But again, I wasn't sure.
克里德还叫约翰“吉米”，我觉得你可以看到约翰快要崩溃了。他说，吉米。我发誓约翰有这种，他有一种侧面的微笑。好吧，在9分29秒，克里德有一个采访。对于任何想知道的人，克里德在说普通话。是的。他说，你好，我的中国朋友。他在普通话里是这么说的。我联系了克里德。是的。因为我们有一个来自KKPL Watson的粉丝提问。他说，克里德在剧中多次说过日语和中文。他真的会说吗？所以我给克里德发了短信。哦，我等不及了。他的回复是什么？这是他说的。他说，你是谁吗？不。但同样，我不确定。
He said, when I was in Germany in 1964, I conversed in a rudimentary fashion because I'd studied a year in college. But he said he hasn't used it since. He says he does not speak Japanese or Mandarin or Cantonese, which is actually the language they speak in Hong Kong, mostly, not Mandarin. But he said, I do have a made up language that I've been trying to get accepted. That I believe.
他说，1964年我在德国时，我用基础方式交流过，因为我在大学学了一年。但他没说他之后就没用过。他说他不会说日语、普通话或粤语，而粤语其实是他们在香港说的语言，主要是，不是普通话。但他确实说，我有一个自创的语言，我一直试图让它被接受。我相信那个。
But he's been meeting resistance and he used it during his stint as manager for that week at Dunder Mifflin. Oh my God. This is Creed, guys. That's Creed. This is Creed. This is Creed. Are you crushing your bills?
但他一直遇到阻力，他在邓德·米夫林担任经理的那一周里用了它。天哪。这就是克里德，伙计们。那是克里德。这就是克里德。这就是克里德。你在还清账单吗？
Defeating your monthly payments. Sounds like you're at the top of your financial game. Rise to it with the BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card. The credit card that rewards your good financial habits. Earn points for paying your credit card bill in full and on time every month. Level up from bill payer to reward slayer. Terms and conditions apply. McDonald's has entered a Minecraft movie universe
战胜你的月供。听起来你在财务游戏中处于领先地位。用BMO Eclipse Rise Visa卡提升自己。这张信用卡奖励你良好的财务习惯。每月全额准时支付信用卡账单即可赚取积分。从账单支付者升级为奖励猎人。条款和条件适用。麦当劳进入了我的世界电影宇宙
and Grimm is Birdie and Hamburglar just spawned as new collectibles in the overworld. Now for a limited time, you can get one of six McDonald's collectibles when you order a Minecraft movie meal with your choice of a Big Mac or a 10 piece chicken McNuggets with spicy Netherflame sauce.
格里姆是伯迪，汉堡神偷刚刚作为新的收藏品在主世界中生成。现在，在有限的时间内，当你订购我的世界电影套餐，并选择巨无霸或10块麦乐鸡配辣味下界火焰酱时，你可以获得六款麦当劳收藏品之一。
A Minecraft movie meal available now at your local McDonald's. See it in theaters April 4th. Meal available for a limited time while supplies last. At participating Canadian restaurants. Do you eat food? Three times the points. Do you go anywhere? Three times the points.
我的世界电影套餐现已在当地麦当劳供应。4月4日在影院上映。套餐在有限时间内供应，售完即止。在参与活动的加拿大餐厅。你吃东西吗？三倍积分。你去任何地方吗？三倍积分。
Do you stream stuff? Three times the points. Well then, get the RBC Ion Plus Visa and earn three times the points at grocery stores and restaurants as well as on gas, EV charging, daily transit, streaming services, digital gaming and more. All the time. Get the RBC ION Plus Visa. Conditions apply.
你流媒体播放东西吗？三倍积分。那么，获得RBC Ion Plus Visa卡，在杂货店和餐馆，以及加油、电动汽车充电、日常交通、流媒体服务、数字游戏等方面赚取三倍积分。一直如此。获得RBC ION Plus Visa卡。条件适用。
Visit rbc.com slash ion cards. All right, at 9 minutes 57 seconds, my character smiles. This doesn't happen very often. And Jenna, I did one of our little dorky actuary things where I gave myself a backstory. For this little smile? For this little moment. So it wasn't scripted, but in the conference room, Dwight is going to now do his speech for us. He has his note cards, right?
访问rbc.com斜杠ion cards。好了，在9分57秒，我的角色笑了。这种情况并不经常发生。珍娜，我做了我们那些书呆子精算师的事情之一，我给自己编了一个背景故事。为了这个小小的微笑？为了这个小小的时刻。所以这不是剧本写的，但在会议室里，德怀特现在要为我们做演讲。他有他的笔记卡，对吧？
And I just sort of gave myself this backstory that he had probably practiced this in front of me, that we had worked on it together. And so I just really beam as he gets up there and I look around to make sure, is everyone watching? Cause I'm really proud of him. So I just had this little thing I gave myself, I didn't tell anyone, but Randall and Matt,
我只是给自己编了一个背景故事，他可能在我面前练习过这个，我们一起努力过。所以我真的在他站起来时容光焕发，我环顾四周确认，每个人都在看吗？因为我真的为他感到骄傲。所以我只是给自己编了这个小东西，我没告诉任何人，但兰德尔和马特，
our camera operators, they caught it and it made it in. And they would often do that. Randall and Matt would sort of catch these little moments that we did in the background that weren't part of the script and they were so great about sort of finding those moments and making sure that everyone saw them. I just like that all of us all the time, we were so invested in our characters
我们的摄像师，他们捕捉到了它，它被放进去了。他们经常那样做。兰德尔和马特会捕捉到我们在背景中做的那些不是剧本一部分的小时刻，他们非常擅长发现那些时刻并确保每个人都看到它们。我只是喜欢我们所有人一直以来，我们对我们的角色投入了那么多
and how our character would react to a moment or to a story that even if we hadn't been directed or didn't think the camera was on us, we would stay in our characters and react in the moment. Yeah. And that's an example of one of those that made it in. Yeah. And I remember Matt saying,
以及我们的角色会对一个时刻或一个故事做出什么反应，即使我们没有被指导或认为摄像机没对着我们，我们也会保持角色状态并在当下做出反应。是的。这是被放进去的例子之一。是的。我记得马特说，
Ang, I see what you're doing. Oh. I'm gonna clock it. I caught it. That was always so fun when they would notice our little choices. Yeah. Aw, I love that. Yeah.
安，我看到你在做什么了。哦。我会记录下来的。我捕捉到了。当他们注意到我们的小选择时，总是那么有趣。是的。啊，我喜欢那个。是的。
Well, then we go to Jim and Dwight's desks, Angela, and Dwight is talking all about the, he's gonna go to New Zealand. I don't know, he tells Jim he should go to New Zealand and walk the Lord of the Rings trail. Okay, I did not understand any of that. Did you understand that? Of course I did.
好吧，然后我们去吉姆和德怀特的桌子，安吉拉，德怀特正在谈论关于，他要去新西兰。我不知道，他告诉吉姆他应该去新西兰走指环王小径。好吧，我一点都没听懂。你听懂了吗？我当然听懂了。
So Jim- You knew what all that stuff meant? I knew what all of it meant, Jenna. But Jim is like, Dwight, where would you, if you could go anywhere, and Dwight was like, I can go anywhere and I will. But one of the places he would like to go is New Zealand because he wants to walk the Lord of the Rings trail
所以吉姆——你知道所有那些东西是什么意思？我知道所有那些东西是什么意思，珍娜。但吉姆说，德怀特，如果你能去任何地方，你会去哪里，德怀特说，我可以去任何地方，我也会去。但他想去的地方之一是新西兰，因为他想走指环王小径
to Modor. I don't know what that is. Is that a place? Modor. Modor is a castle? It's a place. Is it a castle or is it like something hidden under a rock in the ground?
去魔多。我不知道那是什么。那是一个地方吗？魔多。魔多是一个城堡？它是一个地方。它是一个城堡，还是像藏在地下岩石里的东西？
It's a place. Is it a village? Modor is where Sauron rock in the ground? It's a place. Is it a village? Mordor is where Sauron is. Yeah. So where, sorry, what is? Sauron? Sauron. The Eye of Sauron.
它是一个地方。它是一个村庄吗？魔多是索伦藏在地下岩石里的地方？它是一个地方。它是一个村庄吗？魔多是索伦所在的地方。是的。所以哪里，抱歉，什么是？索伦？索伦。索伦之眼。
Is that a thing or a person? I don't know how to describe it. It's pure evil. How can you not describe it? How do you describe the Eye of Sauron? It's like, it's like a, it's like a, like an evil spirit. But it's not a person. Sam, how do I explain Eye of Sauron?
那是一个东西还是一个人？我不知道怎么描述它。它是纯粹的邪恶。你怎么能不描述它？你怎么描述索伦之眼？它就像，它就像一个，它就像一个，像一个邪恶的灵魂。但它不是一个人。萨姆，我怎么解释索伦之眼？
I think it was a person. It was a person. And he's gaining his power back. If he gets the ring, then he can be a person again. Then he can be fully complete, and he will reign pure hell all over the land. So your difficulty in explaining it to me is why I don't like to watch it.
我觉得它是一个人。它是一个人。他正在恢复他的力量。如果他得到戒指，那么他就可以再次成为一个人。然后他就可以完全完整，他将在整个土地上统治纯粹的地狱。所以你向我解释它的困难就是为什么我不喜欢看它。
Well, I'm not because it's like, I don't know convoluted. I'm not as versed in Lord of the Rings. Okay. So that but I do know that the trail to Modor and why would you want to go there? Why are people trying to go to Modor or not trying to go? You don't want to go there. So why does there's like lava fields and all this kind of craziness. And then hike Mount Doom.
好吧，我不是因为它是像，我不知道错综复杂。我不像指环王那样精通。好吧。所以那个，但我确实知道去魔多的小径，为什么你想去那里？为什么人们试图去魔多或者不试图去？你不想去那里。所以为什么那里有熔岩场和所有那种疯狂的东西。然后徒步末日火山。
I think Dwight is like a huge Lord of the Rings fan. He basically wants to be one of the Lord of the Rings. He wants to be on this journey and adventure. Let me ask you this. But it's filmed in New Zealand and it's gorgeous. So I would love to go. Are they the Lords of the Rings because it's their job to keep the rings from the eye of Swarzen? Oh, good God.
我觉得德怀特是一个巨大的指环王粉丝。他基本上想成为指环王之一。他想踏上这段旅程和冒险。让我问你这个。但它是在新西兰拍摄的，而且非常华丽。所以我很想去。他们是魔戒持有者，因为他们的工作是保护戒指不被斯瓦森之眼夺走？哦，天哪。
Or because they want to get the ring to him, so he turns into a regular person again. No. First of all, are you trying to say it wrong? No, I don't. Swarzen? Swarzen? Swarden.
还是因为他们想把戒指带给他，这样他就变回一个普通人了？不。首先，你是在试图说错它吗？不，我没有。斯瓦森？斯瓦森？斯瓦登。
Swarzen. Swarzen. This is like Carl all over again. Okay, moving on. Moving on. 11 minutes, three seconds. Jim does a prank on Dwight. Yeah.
斯瓦森。斯瓦森。这就像卡尔又回来了。好吧，继续。继续。11分3秒。吉姆对德怀特搞了个恶作剧。是的。没有帕姆。是的。这是很久以来的第一次。通常他们一起搞恶作剧。这是一个很好的点。他们是同谋。这是一个吉姆的个人恶作剧。他受够了德怀特那种把这个
Without Pam. Yeah. This is one of the first in a while. Normally they do pranks together. This is a good point. They're in cahoots. This is a Jim solo prank. He's like had it with Dwight sort of shoving this
塞到他脸上，说他要成为年度最佳销售员，吉姆决定，你知道吗？我会给你建议。我大学是演讲专业的，这完全不是真的。不是真的。不是真的。他说，你必须挥动手臂，捶打你的拳头。他给了他们，你必须挥动手臂，捶打
in his face that he's like gonna be like the salesman of the year and Jim decides, you know what? I'll give you advice. I was a speech major in college, which is totally not true. Not true. Not true. And he's like, you've got to wave your arms and pound your fist. And he gives them, you've got to wave your arms and pound
你的拳头。他给了他们一份墨索里尼的演讲稿。是的。他说，这里有一些可能对你的演讲有帮助的东西。我要帮你一把。我在Reddit上发现，Reddit上有一个办公室粉丝，那个人的签名是下划线可替代下划线人。OK。他说，他查了一下，它是转述的，那个人的签名是下划线可替代下划线人。好吧。他说，他查了一下，它是转述的，
your fist. And he gives them a copy of Mussolini's speech. Yes. He says, here are some things that might help you in your speech. I'm going to help you out. I found on Reddit, there's an office fan on Reddit, and the person's sign is the underscore fungible
来自墨索里尼1914年12月13日在帕尔马发表的演讲，主张意大利加入第一次世界大战对抗德国。哇。唯有鲜血推动历史的车轮。现在我想还有一些其他著名独裁者的名言也穿插在其中。是的。
underscore man. OK. And he said, he looked it up, and it's paraphrased and the person's sign is the underscore fungible underscore man. Okay. And he said, he looked it up and it's paraphrased from a speech Mussolini gave in Parma on December 13th, 1914, advocating for Italy to enter into World War One against Germany. Wow. Blood alone moves the wheels of history. Now I think there are some other famous dictators quotes peppered in as well. It is.
它就像一个大杂烩。主要是墨索里尼，我相信。是的。好吧，当德怀特和迈克尔离开时，安吉拉喊道，祝你好运，德怀特。我知道。好吧，在12分钟，当镜头切回会计部的安吉拉时，奥斯卡把外套披在肩上，好像他很冷，凯文在向他的手吹气。但记住，不是奥斯卡说他喜欢冷吗？
It's like the hodgepodge a little bit. Mostly Mussolini, I believe. Yeah. Well, when Dwight leaves with Michael, Angela shouts, the very best of luck to you, Dwight. I know. Well at 12 minutes, when it pans back to Angela at accounting, Oscar has his coat over his shoulders like he's cold and Kevin is blowing on his hands. But remember, wasn't it Oscar who says he likes the cold?
是啊。那他为什么现在假装冷？我不知道，因为凯文也有一个采访说他去把它调到了69度。没错。好了，所以我们进入会议室，帕姆、凯利和瑞安坐着，处理帕姆的“保存日期”卡片。所以这是我们发现的。她的婚礼将在6月10日。
It was. So why is he pretending to be cold now? I don't know because also Kevin has a talking head that says he goes and puts it to 69. Exactly. All right, so we move into the conference room and we have Pam, Kelly, and Ryan sitting, addressing Pam save the date cards. So here's what we find out. Her wedding is going to be June 10th.
我们从游船和招待会上已经知道了，招待会将在退伍军人协会举行。是的，帕姆说它比你想象的要好。是的，我们发现她邀请了吉姆。是的。你们都像什么？有一个很棒的删除场景，它真的是我喜欢称之为“瑞安傲慢”的开始。这将在这一集后面真正发挥作用。有一个删除场景，
We already knew that from the booze cruise and the reception is going to be at the VA Yeah, Pam says it's nicer than you think. Yeah, and we find out she is inviting Jim. Yeah You're all like what there is a great deleted scene and it is really the beginning of what I like to call Ryan sass That's gonna really kick into effect later in this episode. There's a deleted scene Where right before you go into the conference room to assemble your invites, you're at front reception. And Ryan comes in and you're like, oh, did you get my stamps? And he's like, yeah. And he hands them to you and you're like, I wanted the love stamps, you know, the love
就在你进入会议室组装你的请柬之前，你在前台。瑞安进来了，你说，哦，你拿到我的邮票了吗？他说，是的。他把它们递给你，你说，我想要爱情邮票，你知道，爱情
stamps. Yeah. And he goes, yeah, I didn't, I don't know. I didn't find them. I just got you the regular ones. Yeah. And he goes, yeah, I didn't, I don't know. I didn't find them. I just got you the regular ones. And you're like, oh. And then he's like, does it matter? And you're like, yeah, it doesn't really matter.
邮票。是的。他说，是的，我不知道。我没找到它们。我只是给你买了普通的。是的。他说，是的，我不知道。我没找到它们。我只是给你买了普通的。你说，哦。然后他说，这重要吗？你说，是的，这其实不重要。
And he goes, I didn't think so. Oh, Ryan Sass. I know. Wow. All right, so next Dwight and Michael arrive at the convention center. You guys, it's huge. It's insane.
他说，我没觉得。哦，瑞安傲慢。我知道。哇。好了，所以接下来德怀特和迈克尔到达了会议中心。伙计们，它太大了。太疯狂了。
It's full of people. It's an enormous convention room. Way bigger than Michael remembers. Right, and what is playing as they walk through? It's... Y'all ready for this? Yeah, play it, play it. Play it, Sam.
它挤满了人。这是一个巨大的会议室。比迈克尔记得的大得多。没错，当他们走过时在播放什么？是……你们准备好了吗？是的，播放它，播放它。播放它，萨姆。
Y'all ready for this? Okay. We're also watching the music video. We're watching the music video. It's a lot of keyboard. It's by 2 Unlimited. That's the band. And I have to say, that song kind of pumps you up.
你们准备好了吗？好吧。我们也在看音乐录影带。我们正在看音乐录影带。有很多键盘。它是2 Unlimited乐队的。那是乐队。我不得不说，那首歌确实让你热血沸腾。
Super catchy. They play it at a lot of sporting events. They do. Or Salesman of the Year. In Scranton, Pennsylvania. In Scranton. That's right. So, I mean, Dwight kind of starts panicking.
超级朗朗上口。他们在很多体育赛事上播放它。他们确实。或者年度最佳销售员。在宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿。在斯克兰顿。没错。所以，我是说，德怀特开始有点恐慌了。
He is. He's having a minor panic. He's having a minor panic. He's having a minor panic attack. And Angela back in the office is pretending to be sick. I know. She's coughing and sniffling. All of a sudden, she says she's feeling under the weather. She needs to go home.
他正在。他正在经历轻微的恐慌。他正在经历轻微的恐慌。他正在经历轻微的恐慌发作。而办公室里的安吉拉假装生病了。我知道。她在咳嗽和吸鼻子。突然，她说她感觉不舒服。她需要回家。
Yeah. And by the way, still very tan in this shot. Not pale. Not pale at all. So they call Dwight's name and he chokes. He chokes. He's choking. He can't go up. So Michael runs up on stage and we'll bleep this out. This is what I wrote in my note. He shits the bed. Yeah. He really does. So during all of this, of course, I'm trying to look for the dummies that Kent told me about. I'm like, where are the dummies?
是的。顺便说一句，在这个镜头里仍然非常晒黑。不苍白。一点也不苍白。所以他们叫了德怀特的名字，他噎住了。他噎住了。他噎住了。他上不去。所以迈克尔跑上台，我们要把这个消音。这是我在笔记里写的。他搞砸了。是的。他真的搞砸了。所以在这期间，当然，我在试图寻找肯告诉我的假人。我心想，假人在哪里？
I did not notice any dummies. However, at 14 minutes, 19 seconds, there is a shot of the audience and it is, I don't know how to describe it, it's like flipped. It's like it's a mirror image. If you look at the name tags, in every other shot, they are on the right side of everyone's shirts. But in this shot, they're suddenly on the left side and the names are written backwards. What is happening? What is happening?
我没有注意到任何假人。然而，在14分19秒，有一个观众的镜头，它，我不知道怎么描述，它是翻转的。它就像镜像。如果你看名牌，在其他每个镜头里，它们都在每个人的衬衫右侧。但在这一镜头里，它们突然出现在左侧，名字是反着写的。发生了什么？发生了什么？
What? We also had a fan question. Two people asked this. Luke Maslow and Scoot Venenmeyer both asked how much of Michael's speech was improvised. I believe he did improvise quite a bit. However, I have a very strong memory. You know that part when he does Michael Winslow and he does all the different sounds? This is a car starting. Yeah.
什么？我们还有个粉丝提问。有两个人问了这个问题。Luke Maslow 和 Scoot Venenmeyer 都问迈克尔的演讲有多少是即兴发挥的。我相信他确实即兴发挥了不少。不过，我的记忆力非常好。你知道他模仿迈克尔·温斯洛（Michael Winslow）发出各种不同声音的那一段吗？那是汽车启动的声音。没错。
Michael Winslow was this famous actor from the Police Academy movies who could do all of these truly incredible sound effects that sounded super real. And so Michael's trying to do his best Michael Winslow impression. I remember from the table read that that killed. So I feel like that was at least in that was scripted. Were you there for when Steve was doing his portion at all, Angela? Like, do you have a memory?
迈克尔·温斯洛是《警察学校》系列电影中那位著名的演员，他能做出所有这些听起来超级真实的惊人音效。所以迈克尔在尽力模仿迈克尔·温斯洛。我记得在剧本围读时，那段表演效果极佳。所以我感觉那至少是写在剧本里的。安吉拉，史蒂夫表演那部分的时候你在场吗？你有印象吗？
I was waiting to go on. Okay. So I was there. In some takes, they just had me there just in case. And I remember that the audience, the extras, the 400 extras kept getting tickled at Steve. And they had to tell them, you can't laugh. You can't laugh.
我当时在等候上场。好吧。所以我当时在场。在某些拍摄中，他们让我待在那儿以防万一。我记得观众，那些群众演员，那400名群众演员一直被史蒂夫逗笑。他们不得不告诉他们，你们不能笑。你们不能笑。
You can't react, really. You have to hate this speech. You have to hate it. It has to be crickets. So I do remember that. Oh, that's very interesting. Well, finally Dwight runs up on stage, right? Yeah, he gets his courage.
你们真的不能有反应。你们必须讨厌这个演讲。你们必须讨厌它。现场必须鸦雀无声。所以我确实记得这一点。哦，那太有趣了。好吧，最后德怀特跑上台了，对吧？是的，他鼓起了勇气。
He gets out his speech. He starts pounding his fists. And we had a few fan questions. Mary Kay Jones and Sarah Hyland asked, how many times did it take for Rain to get through that speech? So I asked Rain, and he said he thinks he did it about four or five times. Kent told me that on the first take, the background went absolutely wild. Yeah.
他拿出他的演讲稿。他开始捶打他的拳头。我们还有几个粉丝提问。Mary Kay Jones 和 Sarah Hyland 问，雷恩（Rainn）拍了多少次才完成那段演讲？所以我问了雷恩，他说他觉得他大概拍了四五次。肯特告诉我，在第一次拍摄时，背景里的观众彻底疯狂了。是的。
Like hooting and hollering and it was like... The extras guys, the 400 people sitting there. Yes. And that they... Kent said it was kind of phenomenal. Like it was this amazing moment. But the problem was that Greg and Charles McDougall really wanted a buildup of the crowd reaction.
就像大喊大叫，就像……那些群众演员，坐在那里的400个人。是的。而且他们……肯特说这简直太惊人了。就像这是一个了不起的时刻。但问题是，格雷格和查尔斯·麦克杜格尔真的想要观众反应有一个循序渐进的过程。
They did. That the crowd was kind of too instantly with Dwight. They wanted it for the audience to be unsure whether Dwight was gonna be a hit or not. Yes. How is everyone taking this in? So Kent said the first take was pretty unusable. Rain said that he remembers at one point he went off script and he improvised,
他们确实想要。观众对德怀特的反应太快了。他们希望观众不确定德怀特是否会成功。是的。大家对此有何感想？所以肯特说第一次拍摄基本没法用。雷恩说他记得有一次他脱稿了，即兴发挥了，
but then he was directed not to do that again, that they really wanted him to stick to the script. And we had a fan question from Kayla Ardent, did Reign actually have the speech written on that paper? And Reign said yes. He said he did because he thought his character would. Angela, we've talked about that you were there and here's why because you're taping the speech in the background. I'm filming it for him. With your little hat on. I'm filming it. So, so Dwight's speech starts to catch on and Michael can't take it.
但后来他被告知不要再那样做了，他们真的希望他坚持剧本。我们还有一个来自 Kayla Ardent 的粉丝提问，雷恩真的把演讲稿写在那张纸上了吗？雷恩说是的。他说他写了，因为他觉得他的角色会这么做。安吉拉，我们谈过你当时在场，原因就是你在后台录制演讲。我在为他拍摄。戴着你的小帽子。我在拍摄。所以，德怀特的演讲开始受欢迎了，迈克尔受不了了。
Yeah. Michael's like, oh my God, they like him. He clearly can't handle Dwight having a moment of success. He leaves and as he leaves, he walks past my character kind of hidden in the crowd filming Dwight and I'm wearing a hat. So you know how there was a big conversation about your hair and Valentine's? Yeah. Well, Wardrobe and I had a huge conversation about this hat because
是的。迈克尔心想，天哪，他们喜欢他。他显然无法接受德怀特有成功的时刻。他离开了，当他离开时，他走过我这个角色，我当时躲在人群中拍摄德怀特，我戴着帽子。所以你知道关于你的头发和情人节的那场大讨论吗？是的。好吧，服装组和我关于这顶帽子进行了深入的讨论，因为
it was very camera specific. I had to look like I was being incognito, but you had to be able to see my face. So was it written in the script that you're wearing a hat and then Wardrobe had to come up with hat choices? Yes. So we had about, I don't know, five or six hat choices that I had to try on and they took pictures of me in the hat and they showed them to, you know, everybody involved. And then, and then also like on the day I had that hat and I think one other hat and that one showed my face better.
它对摄像机要求很高。我必须看起来像是隐姓埋名，但你又必须能看到我的脸。所以剧本里写了你戴着帽子，然后服装组必须提供帽子选择吗？是的。所以我们大概有五六种帽子选择，我必须试戴，他们拍下我戴帽子的照片，然后给所有相关人员看。然后，在拍摄当天，我有那顶帽子，我想还有另一顶，那顶能更好地露出我的脸。
Okay. So they went with that one. It didn't have too big of a rim. So that's the hat that we went with. I love that little touch that she's gone to record her fellow's speech. Me too. She's so proud of them.
好吧。所以他们选了那顶。它的帽檐不是太大。所以这就是我们选的那顶帽子。我喜欢她去录制同事演讲的那个小细节。我也喜欢。她为他们感到骄傲。
You know, they're sort of meant to be the kind of funny relationship, but they have a really good relationship. They're supportive of one another. They clearly care about one another. It's moments like this that make it so that it's not just a joke. It's not just a joke relationship. These are the moments that ground it and make it real. Listen, Dwight and Angela make perfect sense to me.
你知道，他们本意是那种搞笑的关系，但他们确实有很好的关系。他们互相支持。他们显然很关心彼此。正是这样的时刻让它不仅仅是一个笑话。这不仅仅是一种搞笑的关系。这些时刻让它变得扎实且真实。听着，德怀特和安吉拉对我来说完全说得通。
Yes. They really do. Just like Jim and Pam made sense to me when I read that relationship. And obviously they're going to go through some hills and valleys, but they are meant to be together. I like how Jim's advice ends up being kind of helpful. Well, Jim actually says something to Dwight. He's like, just stay true to yourself.
是的。确实如此。就像我读到吉姆和帕姆的关系时，觉得他们很般配一样。显然他们会经历一些起起落落，但他们注定要在一起。我喜欢吉姆的建议最终起到了一定帮助。好吧，吉姆确实对德怀特说了些什么。他说，保持真我。
Yeah. And that's actually really good advice. This is who you are. Yeah. You're an authoritarian. Yeah. This is how you're going to be most authentic. Yeah.
是的。那确实是很好的建议。这就是你。是的。你是个独裁者。是的。这就是你最真实的样子。是的。
And he kills it. He kills it. We have to go back to the office because there's some Ryan sass happening. Oh, yeah, back in the conference room. Back in the conference room, they're doing Pam's wedding invites. And Kelly says she wants a June wedding and she asked Ryan, would he like a June wedding?
然后他成功了。他成功了。我们得回到办公室，因为瑞恩又在耍嘴皮子了。哦，是的，回到会议室。回到会议室，他们正在处理帕姆的婚礼请柬。凯利说她想要六月的婚礼，她问瑞恩，他想要六月的婚礼吗？
And he's like, yeah, I'm never getting married, not really doing it. And she leaves the room and then Pam is like, you know she likes you. You could be a little bit more sensitive. And he looks at you and he's like, I know what I said. I know. Sass. I know. He and he's like, I know what I said. I know. SAS.
他说，是的，我永远不会结婚，我真的不打算结婚。然后她离开了房间，帕姆说，你知道她喜欢你。你可以稍微敏感一点。他看着你，他说，我知道我说了什么。我知道。耍嘴皮子。我知道。耍嘴皮子。
I know. He's like, no, I know what I did. Ryan SAS. Yeah, Ryan SAS. This is also when Oscar tells Jim that his time share in Key West might be available. But then Ryan says, I don't think Jim will ever really take a trip.
我知道。他说，不，我知道我做了什么。瑞恩耍嘴皮子。是的，瑞恩耍嘴皮子。这也是奥斯卡告诉吉姆他在基韦斯特的分时度假屋可能空出来的时候。但后来瑞恩说，我不认为吉姆真的会去旅行。
Wait. But then Ryan says, I don't think Jim will ever really take a trip. Wait, this is my third Ryan Sass card. At 17 minutes, 34 seconds, he says, you really think you're going to go? Send me a postcard. What is happening? I don't know. Ryan is being such a, you know what? He really is. A lot of fans wrote in and asked if Jim ever takes the trip.
等等。但后来瑞恩说，我不认为吉姆真的会去旅行。等等，这是我的第三张瑞恩耍嘴皮子卡片。在17分34秒，他说，你真的以为你会去吗？给我寄张明信片。发生了什么？我不知道。瑞恩真是个，你知道的？他确实是。很多粉丝写信问吉姆是否真的去了旅行。
Now Paul Lieberstein, who wrote this episode, he did an interview once where he said, yeah, I think Jim did eventually take that trip, but he moved the trip. So he, well, I guess we'll get to that later. I sort of felt like he never took the trip because he just ends up transferring jobs. Yeah. And that's how he gets away. Yeah. But I think he never took the trip.
现在，保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein），这一集的编剧，他曾经做过一次采访，他说，是的，我想吉姆最终确实去了那次旅行，但他推迟了旅行。所以他，好吧，我想我们以后会谈到这个。我总觉得他从来没去过旅行，因为他最后只是调职了。是的。这就是他逃避的方式。是的。但我认为他从来没去过。
I think Ryan's right. I don't think he ever goes. No, I don't think so either. I guess he lost all that money. For the plane ticket. Yeah. All right. So back at the convention, you know, Dwight's speech, we said it's really
我认为瑞恩是对的。我不认为他真的去了。不，我也不这么认为。我猜他损失了所有的钱。为了那张机票。是的。好吧。回到大会现场，你知道，德怀特的演讲，我们说过它真的
starting to kill and Michael leaves. He goes to the bar. Yeah, he can't take it. He can't take that Dwight is doing so well. I bet probably people never reacted like that to Michael's speech. Like people were not like hooting and hollering. No. Yeah. So Michael, he's sitting at the bar, eventually Dwight comes out and he finds him and he starts telling him a story about some woman who sat there who didn't have her ID. But Dwight's so into it. Dwight immediately clicks into Michael's story. Yeah.
开始大获成功，迈克尔离开了。他去了酒吧。是的，他受不了了。他受不了德怀特表现得这么好。我敢打赌，人们从来没有那样回应过迈克尔的演讲。人们没有像那样大喊大叫。没有。是的。所以迈克尔，他坐在酒吧里，最后德怀特出来了，他找到了他，开始给他讲一个关于某个女人坐在那里没带身份证的故事。但德怀特太投入了。德怀特立刻被迈克尔的故事吸引了。是的。
And Michael has this quote where he says, listen, I captivated the guy who captivated a thousand guys. So like, who's the winner today? Who's the winner? Okay, so, Anne, I had a fan question from Madeline Ethington. Okay. This, I've never loved mail more than this mail. Okay, Madeline, wow. Madeline wrote and said, I have been waiting for this episode to ask this question.
迈克尔有句名言，他说，听着，我迷住了那个迷住了一千个人的家伙。所以，谁是今天的赢家？谁是赢家？好吧，安，我有一个来自 Madeline Ethington 的粉丝提问。好吧。我从来没有像这次这样喜欢粉丝来信。好吧，Madeline，哇。Madeline 写道，我一直在等这一集来问这个问题。
What is it, Madeline? At 20 minutes and 25 seconds, when Michael and Dwight are sitting at the bar, you can see a man in the background dressed like a wizard. Why is he there? Why? Was it planned? Was it an accident?
是什么，Madeline？在20分25秒，当迈克尔和德怀特坐在酒吧时，你可以看到背景里有一个打扮成巫师的男人。他为什么在那里？为什么？这是计划好的吗？还是个意外？
And then she just wrote again, who is that wizard? I know the answer to this. I do too. But I didn't know. I went, I was like, this is the strangest question. I went to 20 minutes, 25 seconds, and I laughed out loud. Can we see it? Full head to toe wizard.
然后她又写道，那个巫师是谁？我知道这个问题的答案。我也知道。但我之前不知道。我当时想，这是最奇怪的问题。我看了20分25秒，我大笑出声。我们能看到吗？从头到脚全副武装的巫师。
Well. I took a picture. You have to show me. I know why, but I know why because I watched the deleted scenes. Oh, I know why because I asked Kent Subornak and Paul Lieberstein, why is there a man dressed as a wizard in the background? Okay.
好吧。我拍了张照片。你必须给我看。我知道原因，因为我看了删减片段。哦，我知道原因，因为我问了肯特·苏博纳克（Kent Subornak）和保罗·利伯斯坦，为什么背景里有一个打扮成巫师的男人？好吧。
So you tell me what you found out and I'll tell you what I found out. And here he is, Angela. Yeah. He's got a name tag on. Okay. Well, obviously I don't know Kent and Paul's answer, I found out. Here he is, Angela. He's got a name tag on. OK. Well, obviously, I don't know Kent and Paul's answer, but I watched the deleted scenes.
所以你告诉我你发现了什么，我告诉你我发现了什么。他就在这儿，安吉拉。是的。他戴着名牌。好吧，显然我不知道肯特和保罗的答案，我发现了。他就在这儿，安吉拉。他戴着名牌。好吧，显然我不知道肯特和保罗的答案，但我看了删减片段。
And there is an extended scene of them walking through the hotel where the convention centers are. And they go up to the very first one they see, and they walk in, and it's the wrong one. And it's just some random convention. and then they go into a second room and it's like all of these cosplay people who are dressed like characters from things. Oh. And Dwight's like oh I wish I wanted to go to this it has like a whole name damn it I'm forgetting the name but Dwight was like I would I would have gone. And then he's like, I really hope
有一个加长片段，他们走过会议中心所在的酒店。他们走到他们看到的第一个房间，走进去，结果走错了。那只是某个随机的会议。然后他们走进第二个房间，里面全是那些打扮成各种角色的人。哦。德怀特说，哦，我真希望我想去这个，它有个名字，该死，我忘了名字，但德怀特说我会去的。然后他说，我真的希望
I see the gal from Battlestar Galactica. Oh my god. She's so hot. OK, this must have been improvised because Kent told me that their location agreement with the Sheridan allowed them to shoot basically anywhere on the property, but the only room they were allowed to shut down and control was that ballroom. Yeah.
我能见到《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》里的那个女孩。天哪。她太火辣了。好吧，这一定是即兴发挥的，因为肯特告诉我，他们与喜来登酒店的场地协议允许他们在酒店内基本上任何地方拍摄，但唯一允许他们关闭和控制的房间就是那个宴会厅。是的。
And otherwise, they just had those signs up that said, if you walk in this area, you might be filmed for a TV show. And by walking in this area, you give permission to be on the TV show. I don't know if you guys outside of LA, you see these signs a lot around town. Like you go to a restaurant and there's like a sign and you're like, oh, they're filming on the street and I'm going to be in the background getting my coffee, I guess. So they had these signs up and he said that they just had to allow public access while they were rolling and there was an anime expo in one of the other ballrooms. Yes.
除此之外，他们只是挂了那些牌子，上面写着，如果你走进这个区域，你可能会被拍进电视节目。通过进入这个区域，你即表示同意出现在电视节目中。我不知道你们在洛杉矶以外的地方是否经常看到这些牌子。就像你去一家餐馆，那里有个牌子，你会想，哦，他们在街上拍摄，我想我会出现在背景里喝咖啡。所以他们挂了这些牌子，他说他们必须在拍摄时允许公众进入，而另一个宴会厅里正好有一个动漫博览会。是的。
With people dressed up. So I guess, I guess then Rain and Steve improvised this whole thing that it was like a cosplay convention. They must have. And Rain was really, really bummed, well, Dwight was really bummed because he had wanted to go to it. And supposedly there was a Battlestar Galactica cast member
有很多人打扮成各种角色。所以我猜，我猜雷恩和史蒂夫即兴发挥了这一切，说这是一个角色扮演大会。他们一定是。雷恩真的很失望，好吧，德怀特很失望，因为他本来想去参加的。而且据说有一个《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》的演员
that was gonna be there and he was like really excited. Oh my gosh. Well, both Kent and Paul said a version of the same thing, which was they really tried to avoid getting the dressed up people in the shots, but this one wizard managed to get on camera. And maybe they had to film that little improv to justify it if they,
会出现在那里，他当时真的很兴奋。天哪。好吧，肯特和保罗都说了同一个版本的答案，那就是他们确实试图避免让那些打扮的人出现在镜头里，但这个巫师还是成功入镜了。也许他们不得不拍摄那段即兴表演来证明它的合理性，如果他们，
like too many of them showed up at one time. Yeah, that's amazing. The hotel in the show is supposedly the Radisson at Lackawanna Station Hotel. OK. I have stayed there. Oh. We stayed there for the convention.
如果太多人同时出现的话。是的，那太神奇了。剧中的酒店据说是拉卡瓦纳车站雷迪森酒店（Radisson at Lackawanna Station Hotel）。好吧。我住过那里。哦。我们为大会住在那里。
There was an office convention in 2007, and that's where the whole cast stayed. And it's a lovely hotel. It used to be a train station. Yeah. And like 1908, it was a train station. And they have fixed it up and made it into this hotel and it's really nice.
2007年有一个《办公室》大会，整个剧组都住在那儿。那是一家很可爱的酒店。它以前是个火车站。是的，1908年左右，它是个火车站。他们把它修缮成了这家酒店，真的很不错。
So if you're in Scranton, I recommend the Radisson Lackawanna Station Hotel. Well, when the finale happened, a bunch of us went to Scranton for a big parade and we stayed there as well. So I've also stayed there and I concur. It's a great hotel. Great hotel, super charming.
所以如果你在斯克兰顿，我推荐拉卡瓦纳车站雷迪森酒店。好吧，当大结局播出时，我们很多人去了斯克兰顿参加大游行，我们也住在那儿。所以我也住过那里，我同意。那是一家很棒的酒店。很棒的酒店，超级迷人。
Super charming. So now Dwight and Michael are sort of having this great moment at the bar. They're laughing and it's all wrapping up. But guess who's the last person to touch the thermostat back in the office? Who? Creed.
超级迷人。所以现在德怀特和迈克尔在酒吧里度过了一个很棒的时刻。他们在笑，一切都要结束了。但猜猜办公室里最后一个碰恒温器的人是谁？谁？克里德（Creed）。
Why did I miss that? Creed goes over there and adjusts the thermostat. He's the last one. I missed that. Creed goes over there and adjusts the thermostat. He's the last one. I missed that. Well, at the very end of this episode, Jim is passing by Pam's desk and Pam says, oh, I've always wanted to go to Australia. And he says, well, I'm going.
为什么我错过了那个？克里德走过去调节了恒温器。他是最后一个。我错过了。克里德走过去调节了恒温器。他是最后一个。我错过了。好吧，在这一集的最后，吉姆经过帕姆的办公桌，帕姆说，哦，我一直想去澳大利亚。他说，好吧，我要去了。
I bought a non-refundable ticket. And this is when he tells us he bought his ticket for June 8th. Oh, the look on Pam's face. Her wedding is June 10th. I mean, this is so telling. I mean, Pam, if Pam had any doubts at all that this was hard on him, she can't deny it anymore.
我买了一张不可退款的机票。这就是他告诉我们他买了6月8日的机票的时候。哦，帕姆脸上的表情。她的婚礼是6月10日。我的意思是，这太能说明问题了。我的意思是，帕姆，如果帕姆对这对吉姆来说很艰难有任何怀疑的话，她现在无法否认了。
Yeah, he's leaving. He has basically said to her, I'm sorry, but I cannot be there when you marry someone else. I can't be there. In fact, I have to be on basically the farthest spot on the earth from your wedding. Yeah.
是的，他要走了。他基本上已经对她说，对不起，当你嫁给别人时，我不能在场。我不能在场。事实上，我必须待在离你的婚礼基本上最远的地方。是的。
I'm going to go halfway around the world. Yeah. To get away from your wedding. I mean, I just, it just gutted me. And I just, I just wanted to shake Pam and be like, if you don't know now, then you'll never know! He loves you! But I think it's more than that.
我要去地球的另一端。是的。为了远离你的婚礼。我的意思是，我只是，它让我心碎。我只是，我只是想摇晃帕姆，说，如果你现在还不知道，那你永远也不会知道！他爱你！但我认为不仅仅是这样。
I think what's happening is Jim is saying, I'm not sure how to even be your friend now that you're getting married. Like, I know we're best friends at the office, but I'm not going to come to your wedding. And when you're married, I'm not going to hang with you. I think what he's finally admitting is they're not best friends. Yeah, they can't. How can they be? They've crossed this line.
我认为发生的事情是吉姆在说，既然你要结婚了，我甚至不知道该怎么做你的朋友。就像，我知道我们在办公室是最好的朋友，但我不会去参加你的婚礼。当你结婚后，我也不会和你混在一起。我认为他最终承认的是他们不是最好的朋友。是的，他们不能是。他们怎么能是呢？他们已经越过了这条线。
They've had that moment on Booze Cruise. They've had these moments now, and the line has been crossed. Yeah. And now they're in this uncharted territory of, what do we do now? What's next week's episode? Take Your Daughter to Work Day, I think. Yeah.
他们在“酒水游轮”上经历过那一刻。他们现在有了这些时刻，界限已经被越过了。是的。现在他们处于这种未知的领域，我们现在该怎么办？下一集的题目是什么？带女儿上班日，我想。是的。
Oh, boy. This is when you guys, I was wrong. OK, I used the shredder. Oh, okay. All right. So I'll get the time code for that so I can really lay into myself. Yeah, Take Your Daughter to Work Day
哦，天哪。这就是你们，我错了。好吧，我用了碎纸机。哦，好吧。好吧，我会找到那个时间码，这样我就可以好好反省一下自己了。是的，带女儿上班日
is coming up next week. All right, you guys, that was Dwight's speech. Thanks so much for tuning in. Bye. Bye, see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer
下周就要播出了。好吧，伙计们，这就是德怀特的演讲。非常感谢收听。再见。再见，下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与 Earwolf 合作制作的。《办公室女士》是 Odyssey 的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制片人是 Cassie Jerkins，我们的音频工程师
and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixedber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和助理制片人是 Daniella Silva。Odyssey 的执行制片人是 Jenna Weis-Berman 和 Leah Reese Dennis。《办公室女士》由 Creed Bratton 混音。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。